AFTERNOON WE'RE GOING TO CALL
THE FIRST ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE HEARING TO ORDER-
AGAIN WE ARE VERY FORTUNATE
THAT THIS YEAR CONTINUES A
STRING OF GOOD FISCAL YEARS.
EVEN SYRIA AGREES SO IT'S GOOD-
WE HAVE AT THIS POINT EIGHTY-
TWENTY POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN TOTAL RESEARCH OUR
BUDGET IS STRUCTURALLY BALANCE.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION INCLUDING SOME
OF THE VARIOUS LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS THAT WERE MENTIONED-
DURING LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
DELIBERATION BUT OBVIOUSLY
DIDN'T QUITE MAKE IT IN- IN
PARTICULAR JUST HIGHLIGHTING
SOME OF THE- THE EXPANSION OF
MEDICARE TO- SENIORS OVER SIXTY
FIVE WHO HAPPEN TO BE A
DOCUMENT TO. WE ARE ALSO VERY
MUCH LOOKING THE DISCUSSION
AROUND THE REFORMS AROUND THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
REHABILITATION- IT ALSO- VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE- PROPOSAL
AND DISCUSSION AROUND THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAMS-
OBVIOUSLY THERE WERE SOME- AS
WITH ANY BUDGET DISCUSSION THEY
WERE STILL PROPOSALS THAT. WERE
NOT INCORPORATED THAT WE
OBVIOUSLY WILL BE. RINGING FIVE
BRING FORWARD TODAY TALKING
ABOUT TODAY AND THAT'S- THE
EXPANSION OF THE EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT FOR. ADULTS WHO USE
I TENS WHEN THEY FILE. ALSO
THERE WAS- CONCERNING CUT TO
THE CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
PROGRAM- THAT IS- DEPARTURE
FROM. THE LAST TWO YEARS IN
TERMS OF FUNDING THEY ALSO-
WITHIN SEE QUITE THE INVESTMENT
IN EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
THAT WE HAVE HOPE TO SEE- WE
ALSO. OUR CONCERN THAT MANY OF
THE- PROPOSALS REFERENCE A
SPRING. REGULAR BILL- SOME SOME
SORT OF ALL WAITING TILL WE
ACTUALLY FINISH OUR BUDGET
COMMITTEE DELIBERATIONS TO-
UNVEILED PROPOSALS AND DETAILS-
WHILE LAST YEAR WAS OBVIOUSLY
THE ADMINISTRATION'S FIRST YEAR
WE UNDERSTAND- SOME PROPOSALS
NEEDING TO TAKE MORE TIME TO.
FULLY BE FLUSHED OUT IN TO BE
DISCUSSED GIVEN THAT THIS IS
YOUR TO WE REALLY WOULD HELP AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE TO HAVE-
TRAILER BILLS AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE SO THEY CAN BE
DELIBERATE ON OBVIOUSLY IN BOTH
CHAMBERS. HAVE THE PUBLIC BE
ABLE TO COMMENT ON THEM- IT
ALSO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE-
DISCUSSION OF OUR EIGHTY
LEGISLATIVE MEMBERS AND GET
THEIR FEEDBACK BEFORE. THEY GET
VOTED ON OBVIOUSLY THIS CAN'T
ALWAYS HAPPEN IN EVERY
CIRCUMSTANCE THERE ARE ALWAYS
EXTENUATING CIRCUMSTANCES BUT
AGAIN- WE BELIEVE THAT WE HOLD
OVER A HUNDRED HEARINGS FOR A
REASON- IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DELIBERATE EVERY ASPECT OF THE
BUDGET- IN OUR FIVE DIFFERENT
SUBCOMMITTEES WE HAVE HOURS AND
HOURS OF FRAUD ROBUST. PUBLIC
TESTIMONY ON ALL THOSE ISSUES.
AND WE WOULD HOPE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD JOIN THIS
AND THAT- VIEWPOINT AROUND
TRANSPARENCY AND OPENNESS AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE GET THAT
INFORMATION AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
IN TERMS OF JUST- THE HEARING-
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A MISTER
TWENTIETH AND- SPEAK- FOLLOWED
BY OUR LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
MISTER PADDOCK- AND THEY WERE
GOING TO GO TO MEMBER QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS BEFORE WE START I
WAS GOING TO SEE IF OUR VICE
CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO. MAKE IT A
OPEN REMARKS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I'D LIKE TO JOIN THE
CHAIR IN WELCOMING EVERYONE TO
ANOTHER YEAR OF THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE. I REMAIN
CONVINCED THAT OF ALL THE WORK
THAT WE DO HERE IN SACRAMENTO
THE THINGS THAT WE DO ON
WORKING ON THE BUDGET OR THE
MOST CONSEQUENTIAL FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO ELECTED US. IN FOR
THE RESIDENTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT WORK THAT TO ALL OF
YOU DO SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
IN ADVANCE FOR YOUR HARD WORK
IN YOUR DILIGENCE THIS YEAR I'M
VERY EXCITED. TO WORK WITH YOU
IN CRAFTING THE BUDGET. THEY
WITHOUT MISTER THIS ONE AT THE-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MR
VICE CHAIR I WILL PROVIDE A BIG
THIS OR NOT OF ANY PART OF
FINANCE WILL PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE BUDGET BUT
WE'LL KEEP IT TO LESS THAN FIVE
MINUTES JUST FOCUSED ON THE
OVERALL STRUCTURE SO TO RETAIN
pQUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THE BUDGET IS TO HER TWENTY TWO
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS OVER
ALL OF WHICH APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IS GENERAL FUND IT'S A
BALANCED BUDGET- THAT IS NOT
SIMPLY BALANCE FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR BUT ALSO HAS OPERATING
SURPLUSES IN THE THREE YEARS
FOLLOWING THAT MEETING IN EACH
OF THE FOLLOWING THREE YEARS
AFTER TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WE ARE PROJECTING
THAT WE WILL RECEIVE MORE IN
REVENUE TRANSFERS IN THAT YEAR
AND THE EXPENDITURES THAT WE'RE
PROJECTING FOR THAT YEAR AND
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR A
LONGER TERM BUDGET RESILIENCY
FOR THE STATE. IN ADDITION AS
THE CHAIR MENTIONED THIS BUDGET
BILL SIGNIFICANT RESERVES AND
WE'RE PROJECTING THAT AT THE
END OF THE BUDGET YEAR WE WILL
HAVE TWENTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS
IN RESERVES IN BETWEEN THE
RAINY DAY FUND THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT THE SPECIAL FUND FOR
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES AND THE
SAFETY NET RESERVE WHICH IS
DESIGNED TO PROTECT AGAINST
CUTS FOR MEDI CAL AND CAL
WORKS. IN ADDITION A YOU MAY
RECALL THAT WE HAD SIGNIFICANT
PENSION PAY DOWN SOME LAST
YEAR'S ENACTED BUDGET- IN THAT
BUDGET PLAN WE HAVE PROJECTED
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL COMPLEMENT CALPERS
PAYMENTS OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS DESPITE ACCELERATES ALL
THOSE PAYMENTS OF A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS INTO THE BODY.
INTO THE CURRENT YEAR. I ALSO
RECALL. THAT DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE. OVER THE SUSPEND
PROGRAM IN THE BUDGET ACT THAT
WAS ENACTED LAST YEAR. THIS
BUDGET- PROPOSAL FROM THE
GOVERNOR DOES CONTINUE THOSE
SUSPENDED PROGRAMS TO KEEP THE
BUDGET IN BALANCE BUT DELAYS
THOSE SUSPENSIONS. BY EIGHTEEN
MONTHS SO THAT THEY WOULDN'T
TAKE A FACT. UNDER OUR
PROJECTIONS IN TOLD THE SUMMER
OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE- FINALLY
WHEN IT COMES THE SURPLUS WE
DON'T. WE ARE NOT PROJECT IN
THE TWENTY ONE BILLION DOLLAR
SURPLUS THAT WE HAD LAST YEAR
BUT WE ARE PROJECTING A SURPLUS
FOR THIS BUDGET. OF ABOUT FIVE
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS. AS
WITH LAST YEAR WE DEVOTE THE
LAST. THE VAST MAJORITY ALMOST
80% OF THAT. TWO AT ONE TIME
PROGRAMS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. AND THEN BEYOND THAT
THERE ARE NUMBER OF NEW
INITIATIVES. PARTICULARLY IN
HOMELESSNESS. WILDFIRES IN
EDUCATION- BIG NEW PROPOSALS
AND HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT AND
CLIMATE RESILIENCE AS WELL AS
IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND HAPPY TO GO INTO
ANY OF THOSE- AND QUESTIONS.
AND THEN I THINK THE LAST THING
I'LL SAY IS VERY COGNIZANT OF
THE CHAIRS POINT ABOUT- GETTING
THESE PROPOSALS AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE- I KNOW MY COLLEAGUES
AT THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE MANY
OF WHOM ARE HERE- ARE WORKING
AS- MUCH AS THEY CAN TO GET AS
MANY THINGS READY FOR FABRIC
FIRST. POSSIBLE THERE WILL BE
SUPPOSED DOES. PARTICULARLY IN
SOME BRAND NEW NATION S. FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE HEALTHCARE DRUG
PRICING SPACE. WE'LL TAKE SOME
ADDITIONAL TIME BUT WE ARE
GOING TO BE WORKING. WE
UNDERSTAND THE DIRECTOR THAT.
THE EARLIER PIECE OF. CAN BE
REVIEW THE BETTER CAN BE
CONSIDERED BY THE LAST. THANK.
THANK YOU. GREAT YOU MISS CHAIR
ARM VICE CHAIR AND THEN FOR
HAVE ME HERE TODAY I WAS TO
PROVIDE SOME CALM COULD AND
THREE MAY AREAS ONE OUR OFFICES
VIEW OF THE BUDGET STRUCTURE
INCLUDING THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT BUDGET UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL- A WE HAVE
SOME COMMENTS ABOUT THE SOME
WHAT WE VIEW AS SOME OF THE KEY
CHOICES IN THE BUDGET
PARTICULARLY WITH REGARD TO THE
STATE'S TO ESTIMATED
DISCRETIONARY RESOURCES AND
THEN I WOULD. CONCLUDE WITH A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS- OF OUR VIEW
ON THE IMPLICATION OF THE
OVERALL PACKAGE- FORWARD BEFORE
YOU- ON THE STATE'S BUDGET
CONDITION AND MULTI YEAR FISCAL
OUTLOOK SO WITH THAT WE'LL
BEGIN WITH ON PAGE ONE I HOPE I
HOPE YOU ALL HAVE THIS- HAND
OUT THIS IS- ANY BEGIN WITH A
BRIEF DISCUSSION OF THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT-
PROPOSAL A TALK ABOUT IT
SEPARATELY BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT.
HUNDRED THE UNDER THE STATE
CONSTITUTION PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT ESTABLISHES THE MINIMUM
FUNDING LEVEL FOR SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND SO YOU
CAN REALLY THINK OF IT AS KIND
OF A SORT OF A BUDGET ¢HIN
THE BUDGET AND- FOR THE COMING
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
INCLUDES EIGHTY FOUR BILLION IN
TOTAL PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING THIS IS AN INCREASE OF
TWO POINT FIVE BILLION FROM THE
CURRENT YEAR. NOW THE GOVERNOR
POSES ONE POINT HAVE THAT GO TO
ONGOING PURPOSES PRIMARILY
DEFINED ACOSTA LIVING
ADJUSTMENT AND LOCAL CAN. FOR
ME. BUT HE WAS. ONE POINT ONE
BILLION FOR ONE TIME
ALLOCATIONS- NOW WE THINK THIS
SPLIT IS PRUDENT BECAUSE IN THE
EVENT THAT THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE WERE TO DROP. IT
MEANS THAT THIS THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT BUDGET COULD
ACCOMMODATE THE ONGOING-
PROGRAMS- WITHOUT HAVING TO
MAKE CUTS DESPITE THAT DESPITE
THAT POTENTIAL DROP. ANOTHER
COUPLE OF POINTS I WOULD MAKE
ABOUT THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
PROPOSAL ONE IS THAT MANY OF
THE ONE TIME PROPOSALS DO
APPEAR TO ALIGN WITH THE
LEGISLATURE'S PREVIOUSLY
INDICATED- PRIORITIES. HOWEVER
MANY OF THESE ISSUES ARE LONG
STANDING ONES AND SO ONE
QUESTION WE HAVE IS WHETHER ONE
TIME FUNDING IS REALLY THE BEST
WAY TO ADDRESS THOSE OR IF
ACTUALLY THEY WOULD NEED
ONGOING FUNDING. TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE OVER THE LONGER
TERM. THE OTHER. COMMENT THAT
WE HAVE IS IN IT IN SO FAR AS
THE LEGISLATURE WANTED TO HAVE
THEM THE GREATEST FISCAL IMPACT
FOR THE FOR THE DISTRICTS IT
COULD CONSIDER REPURPOSE SEEN
SOME OF THE ONE TIME
ALLOCATIONS TO- HELPING THE
DISTRICTS PAY DOWN THE LONG
TERM LIABILITIES THAT THEY FACE
WITH RETIREE BENEFITS. IT'S SO
TO THE SECOND PAGE. WHERE YOU
HAVE HERE IS A- IS- SLIDE AND
NOW WE'RE REALLY MOVING AWAY
FROM PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
SO THIS IS SORT OF EVERYTHING
ELSE IN THE BUDGET APART FROM
THE NINETY EIGHT PORTION.
YOU'LL NOTE ON THIS SLIDE ABOVE
THE PIE CHART THERE'S A
REFERENCE TO A SIX BILLION
DOLLAR SURPLUS THIS IS. OUR
ESTIMATE OF THE SURPLUS BASED
ON THE GOVERNMENT GOVERNOR'S A
BUDGET DOCUMENTS. AND IT'S VERY
SIMILAR TO THE SURPLUS THAT WE
ESTIMATE FROM OUR OFFICE VERY
SIMILAR AND THE REASON IT'S SO
SIMILAR IS THAT WE HAVE VERY
CLOSE REVENUE ESTIMATES FOR THE
WINDOW OF YEARS TO COVER THE
BUDGET YEARS SO. 271-919-2020
TWENTY ONE PERFECT DEPARTMENT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S OF
REVENUES IN THE BIG THREE
REVENUE SOURCES ARE ONLY THIRTY
FOUR MILLION ABOVE OURS SO ON
IT IT'S A- NOTABLY CLOSE-
FIGURE. IF WE LOOK AT THE PIE
CHART I CAN GIVE YOU A COUPLE
OF NUMBERS THAT MIGHT BE
HELPFUL- IN THE ONGOING
SPENDING CATEGORY THERE'S ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION. THE
GOVERNOR WOULD ALLOCATE TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION TO
TEMPORARY OR ONE TIME SPENDING-
PROPOSALS AND THEN HE HOLDS ONE
POINT SIX BILLION ASIDE. TO
MAINTAIN THE STATE'S
DISCRETIONARY RESERVE THE
SPECIAL FUND FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTIES AND THEN THERE'S
THREE HUNDRED MILLION IN THE
OTHER CATEGORY. ONE THING YOU
MIGHT HAVE NOTICED IN THE
BUDGET IS THAT THERE ARE A HIGH
NUMBER OF RELATIVELY SMALLER-
PROPOSALS. AND YOU KNOW IN FACT
WE LOOKED AT IT AND THERE IS
WEEK WE ESTIMATE THAT. 95% OF
THE PROPOSALS ARE FOR A HUNDRED
MILLION OR LESS WHICH IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE BUDGET THEY'RE
RELATIVELY SMALL. MOVING TO THE
NEXT SLIDE THREE. THIS FIGURE
DISPLAYS HOW THE GOVERNOR
ALLOCATE FOUR POINT ONE BILLION
IN DISCRETIONARY RESOURCES
ACROSS PROGRAM AREAS THE FOUR
POINT ONE BILLION JUST TO
CONNECT THE DOTS HERE THE FOUR
POINT ONE BILLION IS THE SON OF
THE ONE POINT FOUR BILLION AN-
ONGOING SPENDING PLUS THE- TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION AND ONE
TIME. SPENDING PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR THAT WORK THAT I
MENTIONED ON THE PREVIOUS SLIDE.
AT A HIGH LEVEL THE ONE TIME
SPENDING IS CONCENTRATED AND-
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS. WE'RE AS
THE GOVERNOR'S ONGOING PROPOSE
SPENDING WOULD GO TOWARD HIGHER
EDUCATION AND HEALTHCARE
PROPOSALS. AND IF YOU THINK
ABOUT WHAT I SAID ON THE
PREVIOUS PAGE ABOUT HOW-
THERE'S A HIGH NUMBER OF STE
RELATIVELY SMALLER PROGRAM
PROPOSALS THIS IN OUR VIEW THIS
THIS PRESENTS SOMEWHAT OF A
TRADE OFF FOR THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD YOU RATHER DO THAT OR
WOULD YOU RATHER PURSUE A
SMALLER NUMBER BUT LARGER
TICKET ITEMS SO THAT'S SORT OF
A CHOICE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL HAVE THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET
PROCESS. ANOTHER POINT THAT WE
WOULD MAKE ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
IS THAT SOME OF THE- CONCEPTS-
PUT FORWARD IN THE IN THE
BUDGET PACKAGE HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO EXERT UPWARD
PRESSURE ON THE STATE'S COST
STRUCTURE OVER THE LONG TERM IN
WAYS THAT ARE NOT ACCOUNTED FOR
IN THESE ESTIMATES. SO YOU KNOW
THIS IS PARTICULARLY TRUE WHERE
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES FOR THE
STATE TO- ENGAGE IN ACTIVITIES
THAT ARE SORT OF NEW NEW TO THE
STATE GOVERNMENT FOR EXAMPLE
AND- PRESCRIPTION DRUGS OR
CHANGING THE SCOPE OR MISSION
OF SOME OF THE STATE
DEPARTMENT'S ANOTHER. BABY
MERRICK TO THESE TO THESE IDEA.
BUT WE JUST DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION AT THIS POINT TO
SAY THAT IT WOULDN'T. LEAD TO
HIGHER COSTS DOWN THE ROAD FOR
THE STATE ON AN ONGOING BASIS
SO I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING TO
KEEP IN MIND. MOVING TO SLIDE
FOR HERE WE'RE LOOKING AT THE-
CONDITION OF THE BUDGET- OVER
THE RECENT YEARS IN IS- AS HE
IS BEEN SAID. RESERVES ARE AT
HISTORICALLY HIGH LEVELS ARE A
RESERVE FIGURES TWENTY POINT
FIVE BILLION IN TOTAL UNDER
THE- UNDER THE- GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET FOR TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- IS ONE THING
THAT WE NOTE IN THIS PACKAGE IS
THAT. IN A DEPARTURE FROM
PRACTICE TAKING IN RECENT
BUDGETS THE GOVERNOR DOES NOT
PROPOSED TO. SET IT USE. THE
THIS SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF THE
ESTIMATED SURPLUS TO BUILD UP
THE STATE'S DISCRETIONARY
RESERVES. THAT SAID PROPOSITION
TWO CONTINUES TO DO ITS JOB AND
IS LEADING TO ADDITIONAL
DEPOSITS INTO THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT AND
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE THAT FIGURE
GROWING OVER THE YEARS SHOWN IN
THE TABLE. PAGE FIVE IS HERE-
THIS SLIDE IS SHOWING YOU HOW
WE DISPLAY ESTIMATES OF THE
GOVERNOR'S A SPENDING PLAN
ACROSS THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS.
WHAT I WOULD DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO IS THE DARKER
PORTIONS OF THOSE BARS THOSE
ARE THE OPERATING SURPLUSES AND
WHAT I WOULD SAY ABOUT THOSE IS
THAT WHILE THEY REMAIN POSITIVE
THROUGHOUT THE MULTI YEAR
OUTLOOK THE OPERATING SURPLUSES
ARE SMALL. AND MOREOVER THEY
DEPEND ON SEVERAL KEY
ASSUMPTIONS HOLDING ONE IS THAT
THE ECONOMY CONTINUES TO GROW.
TO THE SECOND AREA IS THAT THE
FEDERAL REGULATORS APPROVED A
MANAGED CARE ORGANIZATION TAX.
pSUSPENSIONS THAT. THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET- FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR DO TAKE EFFECT
THEY WOULD TAKE EFFECT IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE A SOMEWHAT
LARGER- SIR- OPERATINGSURPLUS
IN THAT YEAR I WOULD JUST POINT
OUT THOUGH THAT IF THOSE SIR IF
THOSE SUSPENSIONS DID NOT TAKE
EFFECT IN THAT FINAL YEAR THEN
THERE WOULD BE AN OPERATING
DEFICIT. SO THAT'S JUST
SOMETHING TO BE COGNIZANT OF.
ON THE ON THE LAST PAGE I JUST
WANTED TO LEAVE A COUPLE OF
FINAL OVER ARCHING THOUGHTS
HERE ONE IS THAT WE THINK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
BEGIN THE PROCESS HERE OF JUST
THINKING ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S SATISFIED WITH THE LEVEL
OVERALL LEVEL OF RESERVES
PROPOSED HERE BY THE GOVERNOR.
AND THE OTHER CONSIDERATION IS
THAT- WE SAID IN OUR NOVEMBER
FISCAL OUTLOOK THAT THE- THAT
WE CAN WE HAD A KIND OF A
RECOMMENDED LEVEL OF NEW
ONGOING SPENDING OF ABOUT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS THE PROPOSAL
HERE GOES A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT IT'S ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION GROWING TO ONE BULLET
POINT EIGHT BILLION OVER TIME.
AND THE CONSEQUENCE OF THAT IS
THAT THAT CONTRIBUTES TO THE
VERY SMALL OPERATING SURPLUSES
IN THE THROUGHOUT THE MULTI
YEAR PERIOD. AND IN SO FAR AS
THE LEGISLATURE DID NOT WANT TO
BUILD LARGER DISCRETIONARY
RESERVES SIT IN THE WAY THAT
THE GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING THEN-
AN ALTERNATIVE CONSIDERATION
WOULD BE TO MAINTAIN LARGER
OPERATING SURPLUSES WE THINK
PRESERVING- BUILDING CONTINUING
TO BUILD FISCAL RESILIENCE IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT AT THIS
TIME. THE NO ONE CAN TELL US
FOR SURE WHEN THE NEXT
RECESSION WILL OCCUR BUT WE DO
KNOW THAT THE CURRENT EXPANSION
IS QUITE MATURE WE'RE IN THE
ELEVENTH YEAR OF AN ECONOMIC
EXPANSION AND SO WHETHER IT'S-
HIGHER RESERVES WERE. HOLDING
ON IN PRESERVING A SOMEWHAT
LARGER OPERATING SURPLUS THOSE
WOULD BE- WAYS TO YOU KNOW
UNDER UNDER SCORE- THE STATE'S
FISCAL RESILIENCE AND YOU MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER THAT. SO YOU.
THANK YOU BEFORE BEAGLE WITH
QUESTIONS WE'RE GONNA TAKE ROLE.
TING OBERNOLTE ARAMBULA BLOOM
BRO CHIU COOPER FONG FRAZIER
GALLAGHER GARCIA JONES SAWYER
LACKEY LOW MOAN MATHIS MCCARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN O'DONNELL
PATTERSON RAMOS RADIUS. RIVAS
RUBIO HERE STONE WEBER YEAR
WICKS HERE WHAT. YOUR HOME IS
PRESENT CHRISSY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS.
STRUGGLE TO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SO I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FOR THE D. O. F. AND
ONE FOR THE LA YOU KNOW BUT-
LET ME FREE MY QUESTIONS BY
SAYING THAT I REMAIN VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE OVERALL
LEVEL OF SPENDING INCREASE
THAT'S CONTAINED IN THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL. IF YOU DO THE MATH
AND YOU COMPARE. THIS PROPOSED
BUDGET COMPARED WITH WHAT THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED TWELVE MONTHS
AGO WHICH I THINK IS. THE BEST
APPLES TO APPLES COMPARISON
IT'S OVER 6% INCREASE AND I
KNOW THAT THE FIRST PAGE OF THE
PROPOSED BUDGET SAYS IT'S ONLY
OVER A LITTLE BIT OVER TWO
PERCENT. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THAT'S COMPARED
WITH THE FINAL BUDGET FOR LAST
YEAR NOT THE PROPOSED BUDGET SO
IF YOU COMPARE APPLES TO APPLES
IT'S ABOUT TWICE THE RATE OF
INFLATION WHICH I THINK IS
ALARMING- AND I ALSO AM
CONCERNED WITH THE GROWTH OF
STATE BUREAUCRACY IN THIS
BUDGET WE WERE COUNTING. THE
NUMBER OF NEW STATE
BUREAUCRACIES THAT ARE CREATED
AS PART OF THE PROPOSAL AND WE
STOPPED AT TWENTY FIVE BECAUSE
OF THOSE THOSE THE ONES WE CAN
IDENTIFY SO- AT. THE IN IN A
QUESTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- FOLLOWING UP ON WHAT
MR OF PANIC JUST TALKED ABOUT
ABOUT OPERATING SURPLUS. THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED TO NOT
PUT ANY NEW MONEY IN
DISCRETIONARY RESEARCH IN THIS
BUDGET SO WE'RE INCREASING THE
DISCRETIONARY PORTION OF THE
REST WAS BUT NO NEW
DISCRETIONARY RESERVES. AND LA
LA WAS POINTED OUT. THAT I'M
GOING SPENDING COMMITMENT IS TO
ELIMINATE OUR- SURPLUS I. WOULD
BE MORE PRUDENT TO FOCUS ON.
BUILDING THOSE RESERVES. NOW WE
KNOW WHEN WE HAVE AN OPERATING
SURPLUS AND WE HAVE. A SUCH A
LARGE OF SURPLUS IN- IN
TAXPAYER DOLLARS. THE FIRST
POINT I WANT TO MAKE IS THAT-
THE LA A DETENTION OF THOSE
OPERATING SURPLUSES UNIFIED
OVER TIME- ALTHOUGH THE NAY
INCREASE IN THE LAST YEAR
BECAUSE OF A SUSPENDED
PROGRAMS. BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT DIES
IT'S PRETTY RARE IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS- FOR GOVERNOR
TO PROPOSE ARE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENACT A BUDGET
THAT HAS THAT KIND OF
STRUCTURAL BALANCE NOT ONLY THE
BUDGET YEAR BUTTONS FOR YEARS
FOLLOWING BACK SO- SO THE FACT
IS THAT ALTHOUGH IN SOME OF
THOSE YEARS OPERATING SURPLUSES
LOW. IT STILL IS A POSITIVE
BALANCE AND THAT GOES BEYOND
WHAT IS REQUIRED BY THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION BALLOTS
FOR THE CURRENT YEAR SO WE DO
SEE BALLOTS IN THOSE BACK
SEVERAL YEARS I THINK THE NEXT
POINT ON MAY BE IS- ALTHOUGH
THIS BUDGET DOESN'T MAKE A
DISCRETIONARY. ADDITIONAL
RESERVE COMMITMENTS IN ALL THE
WAYS THAT WE GET IN LAST YEAR'S
ENACTED BUDGET TO THE SAFETY
NET RESERVE- IDEA TO OTHERS. IT
IS STILL PUTTING UNDER
PROPOSITION TWO AS THE LA-
NINETEEN TWO BILLION ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS SO THE RAINY DAY FUND A
SIXTEEN BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
OUR CURRENT PROJECTION OF LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET ACT IT'S GOING TO
BE EIGHTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S OUR PROJECTION OVER
HERE- I ALREADY MENTIONED THE
ACCELERATION OF THE PENSION
PAYMENTS THAT SHOULD HELP TO
SAVE. SOME MONEY AND THEN I
THINK THE LAST THING I'LL SAY
IS UNDER PROPOSITION TWO
THEY'RE ALL THESE REQUIRED DEBT
PAYMENTS AND SO IN THE OUT
YEARS TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
WE'RE PROJECTING AN ADDITIONAL
ONE. ONE BILLION DOLLARS IT'S
ON ALLOCATED AND OUR PROPOSAL I
SENT CALPERS AS SUPPLEMENTAL SO
WE UNDERSTAND THE RISKS AND I
THINK THE LAST POINT ON NAY- TO
YOUR POINT ABOUT THE GROWTH IN
STATE SPENDING. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WAS A CONSTRAINT AS
WE WERE WALKING THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS IS IF YOU LOOK
AT OUR PROJECTED RAP MUSIC
TRANSFERS FOR EACH OF THE NEXT
SUBSEQUENT FOUR YEARS AGO THE
BUDGET YEAR AND THREE YEARS
AFTER THAT. THE RATE OF GROWTH
IN REVENUES IS A LOWER EACH
YEAR THAN THE YEAR BEFORE SO
IT'S LOWER IN 202-120-2220
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND EACH YEAR
FOLLOWING IT IT REDUCES AND SO.
IF WE WANTED TO PROPOSE A
STRUCTURALLY BALANCED BUDGET
WHICH WE DAY WE. HAVE TO
ACCOMMODATE THAT IN THE
EXPENDITURES. WITH THE JAPANESE
ONE. SURE I THINK WORD FURY
AGREEMENT ON ALMOST YOU BUT I
WE'RE WE HAVE A DIFFERENCE
OPINION JUST IS WHETHER NOT WE
SHOULD JUST COMMITTEE ABOUT TO
RESERVE THAT LAW REQUIRES HICH
IS WHY THE- PER. OR WERE WE
SHOULD AS WE DID LAST YEAR
CONTRIBUTES I'M EXTRA TO
RESERVES RECOGNIZING THE FACT
THAT HAS MISTER PETTIT POINTED
OUTWARD IN THE- THE WELL I LIVE
IN FEAR OF OUR CURRENT ECONOMIC
EXPANSION WHICH MAKES IT THE
LONGEST IN CALIFORNIA STATE
HISTORY AT LEAST SINCE WORLD
WAR TWO SO I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S- WHAT I'M ASKING ABOUT A
NIGHT. I KNOW THIS IS THE START
OF OUR SIX MONTH LONG
DISCUSSION HERE I'M VERY
HOPEFUL THAT PERHAPS WE CAN SEE
OUR WAY TO GETTING MORE OF A
PLACE WHERE WE WERE LAST YEAR
WE'RE WE'RE SETTING ASIDE SOME
DISCRETIONARY. HI AND ON THAT.
FOR THE LA I REQUEST ABOUT OUR
RESERVE LEVELS. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL WOULD
END THIS FISCAL YEAR WITH A
LITTLE OVER TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN RESERVES- YOU HAVE
CREATED A RECESSION SCENARIO
FORECAST IS PART OF YOUR
ANALYSIS. THAT SHOWS THAT WE
WOULD HAVE A REVENUE SHORTFALL
OF ABOUT SEVENTY BILLION
DOLLARS. IN A MODERATE
RECESSION WITH AN ACTUAL
DEFICIT OF ABOUT SIX FORTY
BILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE A PROP
NINETY EIGHT. AND SOME OTHER
THINGS SO MY QUESTION FOR YOU
IS WHAT WOULD BE A PRUDENT
LEVEL OF RESERVES. FOR US TO
SEEK BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
NO POINT IN PUTTING ASIDE TOO
MUCH WHAT WE WANT TO BE
PRUDENT. AND PUT ASIDE ENOUGH
THAT'S REQUIRED FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THE STATE'S
SERVICES THEIR CRITICAL IN A
RECESSION WITHOUT RUNNING A
BUDGET DEFICIT. SO OFTEN ARE WE
THERE ARE WE HALFWAY THERE-
WOULD YOU THINK WE OUGHT TO BE
DOING MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU
FOR THE- I. WOULD SAY THAT IN%
OUR RECESSION SCENARIO FROM
THIS- PAST FALL IN NOVEMBER
THERE'S A COUPLE OF KEY
ASSUMPTIONS THAT GO INTO IT THE
FIRST IS THAT WE ARE STARTING
WITH SORT OF THE BASELINE
BEFORE THIS CURRENT BUDGET
PROCESS SO WE'RE KIND OF
INCORPORATING WHAT THE FISCAL
POSITION OF THE STATE WILL BE
AT THE END OF THE FISCAL YEAR
ASSUMING THERE ARE NO ADDITIONS
TO- THE STATE'S COMMITMENT SO
YOU. TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED A NEW NEW
ANSWER BUDGET WOULD REDUCE THE
BUDGET CAPACITY TO WITHSTAND A
RECESSION- AS FOR YOUR
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THE STATE IS
PREPARED I MEAN IT REALLY
DEPENDS ON THE SEVERITY OF THE
DOWNTURN THE SIZE OF OUR
RESERVES AND OUR LEVEL OF
SPENDING RELATIVE TO OUR
REVENUES SO DO YOU KNOW THE
RESERVES CLASS ANY- REVENUES-
ABOVE ARE SPENDING LEVEL THE
SURPLUS OR WHAT PROVIDE US WITH
FISCAL RESILIENCE. TO THE
EXTENT THE RIVER GO TO. WE
WOULD NEED TO EITHER MAKE
PROGRAM CUTS INCREASE REVENUES
OR YOU KNOW DRAW DOWN ON OUR
RESERVES I DON'T KNOW THAT I
CAN. PROVIDE A SATISFACTORY
ANSWER ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
WE'RE PREPARED BECAUSE I THINK
IN LARGE PART IT DEPENDS ON THE
RISK TOLERANCE. OF THE DECISION
MAKERS AND SO- YOU KNOW WHEN WE
CONDUCTED OUR OUTLOOK IN
NOVEMBER WE WERE LOOKING AT
SOMEWHERE IN THE RANGE OF
TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS OF
RESERVES AT THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND YOU KNOW YOU CAN
SEE HERE THAT WANTS TO THE
PROPOSAL IS ACCOUNTED FOR IT'S
A SMALLER AMOUNT IT'S TWENTY
BILLION. AND SO STILL HIS WE
WANT TO PROVIDE US SOME VERY
GOOD CAPACITY WHETHER OR NOT IT
WOULD BE SUFFICIENT KIND OF
DEPENDS ON THE NATURE OF THE
RECESSION. OKAY I THIS IS THE
START OF A LONG DISCUSSION AND
I'M SURE WE'RE GONNA HAVE IT
AGAIN- LET ME MAKE ONE POINT
THOUGH THIS IS. A JUST
CONTINUING SOMETHING THAT YOU
AND I WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
OTHER DAY. ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THE CURRENT LA- RECESSION
SCENARIO INCLUDES. THE
GOVERNMENT CUTTING. STATE
SPENDING ON EDUCATION TO THE
BARE MINIMUM REQUIRED UNDER
PROP NINETY EIGHT. AND THE LAST
TIME THAT WE DID THAT AT THE
STATE LEVEL IT CAUSED.
WIDESPREAD DAMAGE TO OUR STATE
WHAT EDUCATION SYSTEM. I DO NOT
THINK FOR PLANNING PURPOSES
THAT WE SHOULD BE ASSUMING.
THAT WE WILL BE CUTTING FUNDING
FOR EDUCATION. JUST BECAUSE THE
LAW ALLOWS US TO. AND I WOULD
HOPE THAT MOVING FORWARD WE
COULD MAKE A PLAN. THAT WERE WE
COULD RATHER WHETHER RECESSION
WITH OUR RESERVES. I IN A WAY
THAT INCLUDES FUNDING EDUCATION
AT THE SAME LEVEL THAT WE HAVE
BEEN FUNDING IT. RATHER THAN
CUTTING THAT FINAL STATES
SERVICE. IN ONE LAST QUESTION
FOR THE- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
NEVER. REGARDS THE PROPOSED
CLIMATE RESILIENCY BOND THAT
THE GOVERNOR INCLUDED IN THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL SO THAT'S A
FOUR POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR BOND FUND TO FIND A WIDE
VARIETY OF THINGS MOST OF WHICH
I FIND VERY SUPPORT BUT MY
QUESTION IS THIS WE HAVE. A SIX
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET SURPLUS
WHY ON EARTH WOULD WE GO INTO
DEBT. FIVE FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
TO FUND THESE PROGRAMS IN A
YEAR WHEN WE'RE ENJOYING A
BUDGET SURPLUS IF THESE
PROGRAMS ARE SUPPORTABLE AND I
THINK LARGELY THEY ARE. WHY
WOULD WE NOT JUST PAY THE PAY
FOR THOSE THINGS PRIORITIZE
THAT SPENDING AS WE PRIORITIZE
SPENDING FOR EVERYTHINGELSE
RATHER THAN PAYING THEM BACK.
WELL OVER TWENTY YEARS AND
PUTTING- FUTURE LEGISLATORS ON
THE HOOK FOR PAY FOR DEBT
REPAYMENT THAT. SO THREE THREE
POINTS- ON THAT I THINK THE
FIRST AS WELL WE DO HAVE THIS.
FIVE POINT SIX BILLION DOLLAR
SURPLUS AND THAT'S A BIG NUMBER
AND WE CAN EXPECT THAT WILL
HAVE SOMETHING LIKE THAT EVERY
YEAR. AS THE LA MENTIONED- ONE
POINT SIX BILLION OF THAT IS
JUST AN RSS FEED YOU AND THAT'S
OUR RESERVE ACCOUNT FOR. ANY
SORTS OF EMERGENCY OR ANYTHING
ELSE THAT. COMES UP AND IN
ADDITION TO THAT I SOME
EXPENDITURES THAT WERE MAKING
OUT OF THAT SURPLUS OUR
EXPENDITURES THAT WE REALLY DO
NEED TO MAKE AND SOME OF THEM-
ARE ACTUALLY IN THIS AREA OF
WILDFIRES IN ABOUT SETTING UP.
PUTTING MORE MONEY INTO CAL
FIRE THE WILDFIRES RIGHT
INTEGRATION CENTER- SOLAT IN
THAT SPACE- SO WHEN YOU
ACTUALLY THINK ABOUT. WHAT'S
REALLY NO IT'S ALL
DISCRETIONARY BUT ONCE YOU
THINK ABOUT THE EXPENDITURES
THAT THE GOVERNOR FELT AT LEAST
WERE VERY IMPORTANT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION- THERE WASN'T
FOUR FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE JUST FOR THIS ONE SET
OF ITEMS. I THINK THE SECOND
POINT THAT I WANT TO MAKE IS
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT-
INFRASTRUCTURE I SPENDING- FOR
ITEMS LIKE THIS- BONDS RGO
BONDS ARE APPROPRIATE. TO YOUR
POINT IT IS ALWAYS CHEAPER TO
PAY IT OUT RIGHT AND TO SELL
GEO BONDS BECAUSE THERE ARE.
THERE IS AN. FLOOD PROTECTION
DROUGHT WATER- COMMUNITY
HEARTENING THESE ARE THE TYPES
OF THINGS THAT BONDS ARE
APPROPRIATE FOR BECAUSE IT IS
THE CASE AS YOU MENTIONED THAT
THE BURDEN. WILL BE BORNE BY IN
FUTURE BUDGETS AS WELL BUT THEY
WILL ALSO RECEIVE THE BENEFITS
OF THOSE LONG TERM INVESTMENTS.
AND THEN THE FINAL POINT I'LL
MAKE IS YOU KNOW I. CAN'T
PROFESS TO PROJECT WHERE
INTEREST RATES ARE GOING IN THE
FUTURE YOU KNOW WE HAVE OUR
BEST ESTIMATES BUT AS YOU KNOW
INTEREST RATES ARE AT A LOWER
LEVEL. RIGHT NOW THAN THEY HAVE
SOMETIMES BEEN IN THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS OR DECADES SO.
ALL OTHER THINGS BEING EQUAL WE
THOUGHT THAT THIS WAS AN
APPROPRIATE USE OF RESOURCES-
FOR THE PURPOSES OF THE BOND.
SO APPRECIATE ANSWER HOW YOU
AND I DISAGREE ON THAT. I THINK
THAT. WHEN WE'RE ENJOYING
BUDGETARY SURPLUS IS THE TIME
TO MAKE INVESTMENTS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH CURRENT
DOLLARS. AND WHEN WE HAVE
DEFICITS IS THE TIME THAT. WE
MUST BORROW TO MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE. THE ONGOING FUNDING FOR
IT AND WE IN THE NEEDS TO
CONTINUES TO EXIST. FOR THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE SO- I WOULD.
MUCH PREFER US TO. NOT GO
FURTHER IN DEBT IN YEARS WHEN
WE HAVE A SURPLUS LIKE WE DO.
THIS YEAR AND ALSO MAKE THE
POINT THAT. I EVEN AS- YOU
POINT OUT THAT INTEREST RATES
ARE- THAT ALMOST A STORE CLOSE
RIGHT NOW- IT'S STILL THE CASE
THAT BORROWING THAT MONEY OVER
TWENTY YEARS IS GOING TO
REQUIRE. A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT
OF INTEREST BEFORE IT'S REPAID
IN FACT. I EVEN A TODAY'S
INTEREST RATES I THINK IT'S
OVER EIGHTY PERCENT- EXTRA THAT
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO BE
REQUIRED TO INPUT A DIFFERENT
WAY WE COULD BUILD. ALMOST
TWICE AS MUCH NFRASTRUCTURE.
FOR DOLLAR THAT WE SPEND IF WE
DO IT ON AN ONGOING BASIS
RATHER THAN BORROWING. SO I
WOULD MUCH PREFER THAT WE- THAT
WE FIND THAT OUT OF. OUR
ONGOING BASIS. IN YEARS WHEN WE
HAVE A SURPLUS AS WE DO THIS
YEAR. BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE ANSWER- AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
BOTH- IN THE MONTHS TO COME AS
WE CRAFT THIS BUDGET. THANKS
THANK YOU. MISS GARCIA. AT
THANK YOU WANTED- COMMENT AND
QUESTIONS ON THREE DIFFERENT.
AREAS IN THE BUDGET THE BOOK
THE FIRST IS RELATED TO AB SIX
SEVENTEEN AND OUR COMMUNITY OR
PROTECTIONS- I SEE THAT THERE
HAS BEEN. SLIGHT CUT IN IN THIS
AREA EVEN THOUGH WE'VE ADDED
FIVE ADDITIONAL COMMUNITIES FOR
YOUR TO COMMUNITIES FIGHT THAT
A FINE HOT SPOTS CREATING
COMMUNITY ACTION PLANS. AND
THEN IMPLEMENTING THOSE PLANS-
AND SO JUST WANTED TO KNOW A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE
RATIONALE THERE FOR THOSE CUTS.
SO ALL MAKE A BRIEF POINT AND
THEN MY COLLEAGUE THREE SECOND
TALK SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE
PROGRAMS AT THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED IN HIS BUDGET A TWELVE
AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS
CLIMATE BUDGET OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS AND THAT INCLUDES-
CAP AND TRADE AS YOU MENTIONED
REVENUE FROM THAT PROGRAMS. AS
WELL AS THE CLIMATE CATALYST
FIND AND THEN FINALLY THAT BOND
FUNDING THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE MENTIONED ARE
PROJECTION FOR THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM THIS YEAR IN
TERMS OF REVENUES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO. IS A LAST THAN IT
WAS LAST YEAR WE HAD A SURPLUS
OF FUNDING LAST YEAR THAT WE
DON'T ANTICIPATE WILL COME.
THIS YEAR SO WE HAVE TO THINK-ABOUT THE GOVERNOR HAD TO THINK
ABOUT HOW WE ALLOCATE A SMALLER
BUCKET OF FUNDING AMONG THE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS SB SIX
SEVENTEEN AND COMMITTEE OR
PROTECTION STILL IS A BIG
PRIORITY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND ALTERNATE
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE TO RESET
TO SPEAK ABOUT. THREE OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND- YES
LAST YEAR COMBINED AB SIX ONE
SEVEN PROGRAMS TOTALED ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION FROM THE GT R. F. THIS
YEAR IT'S TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE. AND THE PRODUCTION
WAS TO THE LOCAL PROGRAMS- FROM
TWO HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILLION
TO TWO HUNDRED MILLION PROPOSED
THIS YEAR. AND THE LOCAL OR
DISTRICT IMPLEMENTATION-
ACTUALLY WENT UP BY FIVE
MILLION FROM TWENTY TO TWENTY
FIVE AND THEN THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO COMMUNITY GROUPS
STAY THE SAME AT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS. BUT A LOT OF THE
CHANGES AGAIN ATTRIBUTED TO.
LAST YEAR'S CAP AND TRADE
FUNDING BEING MUCH HIGHER THAN
WE HAVE HERE AND FOR
DISCRETIONARY PROGRAMS THIS
YEAR. I MEAN AND SO I WOULD SAY
THAT AB SIX SEVENTEEN DOESN'T
JUST NEED TO BE. SHOULDN'T JUST
BE FROM THERE FROM CAP AND
TRADE WE SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT IT ONLY THING ABOUT. THE
GOVERNOR'S PLEDGE OF JUSTICE
FOR ALL. ON A WHEN YOU'RE-
ABOUT A HOLISTIC. APPROACH
LOOKING WHAT THAT OUR RESOURCES
BONDED. AND OTHER ITEMS AND
THIS ONE BILLION DOLLAR
CLIMATE. OF INITIATIVE HE
STARTED- I THINK WHAT'S SPECIAL
ABOUT EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN THAT
IS TARGETING ANIMALS AFFORDABLE
COMMUNITIES OR COMMUNITIES THAT
OFTEN FOR ABOUT ANYTHING ELSE
HELP. ON AND SO WE IN WE ARE.
CONTINUOUSLY THE PLAN IS ADDED
TO THE COMMUNITY AND SO WE CAN
BE SAYING WELL BECAUSE HE
EXPECTS LESS PER- PROJECTIONS.
RAINY MAKING THESE CUTS WITH A
PROGRAM SUPPOSED TO BE CRYING
SO I THINK. WHEN YOU LOOK
BEYOND. CAP AND TRADE. HOW DO
WE HONOR AND HOW DO WE HONOR
THE GOVERNOR'S WILL OF JUSTICE
FOR ALL AND NOT JUST. FOR SOME.
OUT THERE WITH EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN AND SO. LIKE I BY
SURE NATURE HAS ANYWHERE IN THE
BEGINNING OF LONG NEGOTIATIONS
BUT I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE THINK ABOUT
OUR COMMITMENTS. THAT WE HAVE
MADE AND WHAT'S SPECIAL ABOUT
THESE COMMUNITIES IN THE WORK
THAT'S BEING DONE HERE- AND I
THINK WE'RE AT A CRITICAL POINT
WHICH IS FINISHED THE YEAR ONE
PLANTS A CERTAIN TO GET IT.
SAID A LOT OF LESSONS LEARNED.
STARTING WITH THE YOUR PLANS. I
THINK NEED TO. THIS
HANDICAPPING THE MUST THE
PROGRAMS. TO GO ON DEVELOP. ON.
THEIR I AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING.
SO WANTED TO ME THAT. I WANT TO
ALSO LOOK. THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF TOXIC. SPECIFICALLY TOSCA
AND THE TOUGH GUY COUNT THAT WE
HAVE. LAST WHEN WE DISCUSSED
THIS ITEM HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE. WE PROTECT THE TOSCA
TO POTENTIALLY BE INSOLVENT IN
THREE YEARS. ON AND WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE BUDGET RIGHT NOW
IN THE MONIES THAT ARE HERE
RIGHT NOW LOOKING. AND THE
BALANCE OF. SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS- WHICH
MEANS THAT WE HAVEREALLY NO
SPACE FOR ANYTHING TO CHANGE
AND EVERYWHERE ANY VERY
ABILITY. ANA IN THERE AND SO
LOOKS EVER BECOME INSOLVENT
MUCH QUICKER. THAN WE HAD.
ANTICIPATED AND OUR ESTIMATES
CHANGE I UNDERSTAND THAT-
WE'VE- DONE WE THEN HAVE A
PROPOSAL OF GENERAL FUND MONIES
THAT ARE MOVED. INTO ONE SPOT
AND THEN SEE TO MOVE TO ANOTHER
SPOT. INTO THIS IS TO BE THE
SHUFFLE. OF MONEY THAT KIND OF
HE'S TOO HIGH TO OUR PROBLEMS
WHICH IS ONE OF THE CRITICISMS
WE HAD LASTYEAR. AND SO THIS
IS NOT A SHUFFLING OF DOLLARS
AND THERE'S A RUSSIAN OFFER
THIS. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION EXPLAIN
TO US WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
WITH HIS ACCOUNT AND HOW WE'RE
MOVING GENERAL FUND MONIES. IN
THERE BECAUSE WHEN I JUST READ
IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE SHUFFLING.
WHEN YOU'RE ABOUT TO HAD A
PROBLEM AND WE HAD A DAY
THROUGH. A BUDGETING SEEK TO
THESE NUMBERS OF REALLY WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH TASK AND HOW. THE
CITY CHANGED LAST YEAR TO THIS
YEAR BUT EVERY DOING WITH.
ACTIONS YEAH SO IT IS AN AREA
WILL DEFINITELY AT MINISTRATION
RECOGNIZE TO THE BUDGET. THAT'S
NEAT ABSTRACT TENSION AND INTO
SPECIFIC AREAS ONE. IS WITH
REGARD TO THE FEE STRUCTURE AND
THEN SECOND WITH REGARD TO
GOVERNANCE REFORMS ARE TO RESET
CAN SPEAK ABOUT BOTH OF THOSE
AREAS. RIGHT SO THE DEPARTMENT
TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL IS AN
GOING TO HAVE A- BIGGER- MORE
DETAILED PACKAGE COME FEBRUARY
FIRST ALONG WITH TRAILER BILL
AND MORE DETAIL BEHIND THE
PROPOSAL. YOU ARE CORRECT THAT
THE TOSCA FIND IT DID REQUIRE A
TWELVE MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
FUND BACK FILL IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WHICH IS PROPOSED. BUT WE
ARE HAPPY TO. SIT DOWN AND GO
THROUGH WITH A BUDGET COMMITTEE
STAFF IN MORE DETAIL KIND OF.
TO THE FUN CONDITION TO
EXPLAINS ANY OF THE I CHANGES.
BUT THERE'S NO INTENT TO
SHUFFLE DOLLARS AROUND BY WE
KNOW. WITH UPDATED ESTA. I AM
THE FALL THAT TOSCO WAS. MEDIAN
AGE FUND FILLED KIND OF KEEP.
IS ABOUT TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS. AND HOW IS IT THAT WE
HAVE THAT DISCREPANCY IN LAST
YEAR'S ANALYSIS WITH THAT THAT
WE THOUGHT WE HAD THREE YEARS.
BEFORE WE GOT TO THIS POINT.
BUT THEN IN THIS. CURRENT
BUDGET IF YOU'RE TELLING US
THAT WE GOT TO THIS POINT.
RIGHT HERE REQUESTED AND SO
WHAT THE DISCREPANCY THERE HOW
DID WE MISS ESTIMATES ABOUT. SO
THEY COULD BE I AM DIFFERENCES
IN. ANTICIPATED EXPENDITURE
LEVELS THAT CAME IN FROM THE
PRIOR YEAR ALSO ANTICIPATED
REVENUES- AND SHE'S NOT
MATERIALIZING AS IS PLUS ANY
INCREASED COSTS THAT WEREN'T
PART OF THAT ORIGINAL ESTIMATE-
I DON'T RECALL THE THREE YEAR
TIME FRAME I KNOW IN OUR BUDGET
SUMMARY PAGES IN THE MAYOR OF
IT. LAST YEAR I BELIEVE WE
REFER TO KIND OF THE BOTH OF
THE FUNDS BEING BOOKED OUT
MORE- AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
TOSCA. ART SIX REFORM EFFORTS
SO AGAIN WE CAN. TRY TO GO TO
THE FUND CONDITION IN MORE
DETAIL WITH BUDGET SOUTH THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN HELP WITH.
THAT WE NEED MORE. I GUESS BUT-
LAST WE HAD AT THIS WITH THE
SAME DISCUSSION EARLY ON IN A
CONTINUED AND I THINK IF I GO
BACK TO THE GOVERNOR'S SCHOOL
OF JUSTICE FOR ALL THIS IS
ANOTHER PART OF THAT PIECE
THERE OVERLOOKING AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUES
OVER LOOK AT TAXES WERE LOOKING
AT THE SAME COMMUNITIES ARE
REALLY IN ONE ISSUE AFTER
ANOTHER. OUT THERE- WE WANT TO
ASK A TO BE HEALTHY WE WANT IT
TO WORK WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE MONEY TO THE SITE
WE MEDIATION OFFER BROWNFIELDS
AND SUPER FUNDS AND DO OUR PART
SIDE WITH THE BUT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S DOING WE ONE KELLY
P. TO BE NEEDING IT'S YOU KNOW.
IT'S GOAL AT OF HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES AT THE WE FORGET
THAT OFTENTIMES TIED INTO THIS
AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF THAT AND
IN MY DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION- IT SEEM LIKE
WITH. WHAT YOU'RE TELLING ME
THEY ANYTHING TO ME WAS THAT
THEY HAD A THING TO ME LAST
YEAR WITH THINGS THAT HAVE
CHANGED ON AND SUCH AS AS WE'RE
MOVING FORWARD AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HOW TO STABILIZE.
THE TOSCOACCOUNT LONG TERM HOW
TO MAKE SURE THAT MONIES ARE
BEING RESPECTED WITHIN THE PROP
TWENTY SIX SPECTRUM
INTERNATIONALLY THINGS AROUND
THAT THATALSO THAT I ASK
MYSELF THE QUESTION IS THIS.
TWELVE MILLION AS WE MOVE TO
ONE SPOT IN THAT ELEVENTH AND
THEY'RE MOVING DIRECTLY AGAIN
THE WAY TO GET AROUND SOME OF
THAT MISSION- THERE AND SO I
THINK THAT THERE'S A LITTLE BIT
OF DISTRUST FROM MYSELF AND
OTHER PEOPLE ON HERE. ABOUT OUR
COMMITMENTS I'LL. IN THIS
SPACE. ON THE THIRD ITEM TAKE
TO THIS AND THIS. IN THE SAME
ISSUE AREA BUT THE GUY.
THANKFULLY ABOUT THE T. BEFORE
BRIEFLY. THAT THERE'S THE
SENTENCES IN THE BUDGET WE'VE
BEEN ASKING FOR LANGUAGE WE'VE
HAD A BILL PARKED IN THE SENATE
SINCE LAST YEAR- WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THAT FOR FOUR YEARS-
AND THE LEGISLATURE WEEK. WE
AGREED TO GO AHEAD AND LET A
PARK EXPECTING. SOME REAL
LANGUAGE- WHEN THE RESTRICTED
BUT YOU CAME OUT IT HASN'T COME
OUT. AND SO WHEN I AM I GONNA
BE ABLE TO SEE THAT LINE WHICH
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE ON THE SAME
PAGE OR NOT. OXEN HERE FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AND- STAKEHOLDERS
ARE SHARING DETAILS. ABOUT THE
T. C. REFORM THAT. ON THE
HEARING ABOUT INSIDE MY FORCES
ARE COMING FROM. SURE OUR TIME
FRAME FOR BOTH THE FEE AND
GOVERNANCE TRAILER LANGUAGES
THE FEBRUARY FIRST TIME FRAMES-
FOR TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ASSOCIATE OF THE JAN TEN
PROPOSAL SO THAT IS A TIME FOR
MORE WORKING ON. SO I'LL KEEP.
HAMMERING ON THESE THINGS ARE
PER. I DISTRICT A PERSONAL TO
OTHER DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE IS NOT JUST AN ISSUE OF
THE FIFTY EIGHT BUT- AN ISSUE
OF COMMUNITIES THE COLORS OF
THE COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES
THAT WE SEE IN AREAS LIKE
SOMEWHERE DINO. SHAFTER FRESNO.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- AND SO I
THINK AS THE GOVERNOR HE'S
TALKING ABOUT A BUDGET. AND
POLICY. AND JUSTICE FOR ALL
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ACTUALLY HONOR THAT FIFTEEN
THAT'S WHERE WE HAVE COMMON
GROUND. WITH MYSELF IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE LEADERSHIP
OF BEEN DOING AND THE SPACE.
THANK YOU. DOCTOR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- YOU KNOW I
WANTED TO SHARE A FEW
OBSERVATIONS AND- OPINIONS IF I
COULD WITHOUT INHERENTLY
GETTING TO DIRECT QUESTIONS AND
THE FIRST ONE THAT I COULDN'T
HELP BUT NOTICE IS HOW WELL
WORN THE LA OWES- TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET IS
WITH NOTES AND HAND WRITING.
AND THEN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ALMOST SEEMS LIKE IT'S AN OPEN
AND IT MAY BE BECAUSE YOU
ACTUALLY WROTE IT BUT- WANT TO.
JUST TAKE KNOWLEDGE. MANY OF US
HAVE SPENT SIGNIFICANT TIME
DIGGING AND- JANUARY TENTH AS
THE DAY I LOOK FORWARD TO BEING
ABLE TO READ THE BUDGET IN HERE
ARE GOVERNOR HELP TO PROVIDE A
VISION FOR OUR STATE AND SO I
DID WANT TO START WITH AN
APPRECIATION FOR HIS
UNDERSTANDING AND BEING A REAL
HEALTHCARE GOVERNOR ONE WHO.
IS ATTEMPTING TO DO SOME BROAD
REFORMS- INITIALLY WAS CALLED
CAL LAME IT IS CHANGED TO MEDI
CAL HELD HERE FOR ALL BUT THE
IDEA OF CARE COORDINATION WITH
THE INCREASINGLY COMPLEX SYSTEM
AS WELL AS PATIENTS WHO ARE.
UNABLE TO NAVIGATE THOSE
SYSTEMS IS INHERENTLY IMPORTANT
AND- GOOD WORK I LOOK FORWARD
TO BEING ABLE TO DISCUSS THE
ENHANCED CARE MANAGEMENT THE
BENEFIT THAT COMES WITH THAT AS
WELL AS THE IN LIEU OF SERVICES
AS THOSE WRAPAROUND SERVICES
HAVE LONG BEEN NECESSARY WITH
AND HEALTH CARE TO HELP US TO
AVOID COST DOWNSTREAM AND-
THINK THAT ABILITY FOR US TO
HAVE A HOLISTIC APPROACH WILL
REALLY HELP US. TO REACH
AFFORDABILITY WOULD BE REMISS
NOT TO GIVE ME PERSONAL THANKS
TO THE GOVERNOR AND DEPARTMENT
FINANCE AND EVERYONE WHO HAS
ADVOCATED FOR HEALTH FOR ALL
ELDERS AND OUR ABILITY TO
EXPAND TO ARE UNDOCUMENTED
BUILDERS IS A SIGNIFICANT STEP
AND- IS APPRECIATED FROM MYSELF
AS WELL AS MY DISTRICT. I DO
HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT MANY OF
THE- THAT MAY BE COMING UNDER
SOMEONE'S PURVIEW SUCH A- THE
DEPARTMENT OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT THE CENTER FOR DATA
INSIGHTS AND INNOVATION AND
THE- OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION BUT ALL
SAVE MANY OF THOSE QUESTIONS
FOR SUB ONE OF WILL WANTS TO
REALLY LOOK AT THE DETAILS OF
IT. I DID WANT TO BRING UP- ONE
OF THE TWO THIRDS ISSUES WITHIN
THE BUDGET WHICH MAYBE THE
BEEPING. ISSUE THE USE PEIPING
EPIDEMIC THAT WE HAVE. THERE'S
WITHIN THE BUDGET IT DISCUSSES
HELD WORK FORCE. EXPANSION IS
AND- I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE US
TO LOOK FOR A LONG TERM FUNDING
SOURCE FOR THE MEDICAL LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM THAT WE'VE
DONE FOR BOTH. DOCTORS AND
DENTISTS WE HAD PUT ONE TIME
MONEY INITIALLY FROM PROP FIFTY
SIX. BUT SINCE THIS WILL BE A
CONTINUING STREAM THERE MAY BE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO TIE IT TO
THAT LONG. TERM LASTLY IF I
COULD I. ADVOCATING FOR A LONG
TIME AND REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
THE GOVERNOR SPENDS TIME TO
COME DOWN TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FOR AN ECONOMIC SUMMIT THIS
YEAR. AND HELPED TO MAKE SOME
OF THE INVESTMENTS THAT WE WERE
SUGGESTION WITHIN THE FRESNO
DRIVE. WHETHER IT BE FOOD
PRECISION CORRIDOR BETWEEN
FRESNO STATE AND YOU SEE MERCED
OR- THE SEVENTEEN MILLION FOR A
K. THROUGH SIXTEEN
COLLABORATIVE TO HELP US
IDENTIFY EMERGING INDUSTRIES
AND- WHERE THE FUTURE OF WORK
WILL GO. FOR THE FIFTEEN
MILLION THAT WENT INTO THE
FRESNO- MEDICAL SCHOOL THESE
TYPES OF INVESTMENTS ARE
GREATLY APPRECIATED AND HAS
SHOWN HIS CONTINUED COMMITMENT.
TO AREAS OF THE STATE THAT HAVE
BEEN HISTORICALLY GOTTEN THAT
SUPPORT AND SO JUST WANTED TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AS
WELL AS- APPRECIATE- THE
GOVERNOR'S CONTINUED SUPPORT.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING A
WONDERFUL YEAR FIGURING OUT-
MANY OF THE PROGRAMS THAT I'VE
SPOKEN TO TODAY. THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU DOCTOR WHAT.
BUT YES THE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE WORK THAT'S INTO OF THE
BUDGET- THIS APARTMENT DIRECTED
PART OF FINANCE HERE THERE'S
SOME PRETTY BOLD PROPOSALS-
WITH REGARD TO HEALTH CARE
WHICH IS REALLY EXCITING TO ME
AS A AS A PROVIDER AND THE
CHAIR OF THE HEALTH COMMITTEE-
BUT THERE'S ALSO SOME THERE
THERE'S PRETTY WELL PRETTY
LIGHT ON DETAILS- AND SO I AM
CURIOUS AS TO WHEN WE WILL SEE
THAT WE KEEP HEARING OF
FEBRUARY FIRST DAY. BUT BUT
I'VE ALSO HEARD OTHER DATES SO.
AS IT RELATES TO THE BUDGET
AND- WHEN WE GOING TO GET MORE
INFORMATION ON SAY FOR EXAMPLE-
THE PRESCRIPTION AND THE-
MANUFACTURING FOR PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS- OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE-
AFFORDABILITY- WHEN WE GET SOME
MORE DETAILS AT THIS POINT ON
THOSE ISSUES. SO AS OU
MENTIONED THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT PROPOSALS THAT ARE
NEW THIS YEARIN THE HEALTH
CARE SPACE AND I'D KIND IS A
MIGHTY ONE WOULD LOOK AT IS TO
SEPARATE THEM INTO A- COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES SO I THINK
THERE'S SOME WAY OR IT'S VERY
CLEAR WHAT IT WILL LOOK LIKE
AND- HOW WILL OPERATE EVEN IF
IT IS A BIG TICKET ITEM AND SO
AN EXAMPLE THIS IS THE
EXPANSION OF MEDICARE HOW. TO
THE UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION AGE
SIXTY FIVE IN ABOUT THE
INCLUDING AYE HSS- PREVIOUS
BUDGETS HAD DONE THAT UP TO AGE
NINETEEN IN THE BUDGET ENACTED
LAST YEAR TO TAKE TWENTY SIX
SALT THE DIFFERENT POPULATION
WITH DIFFERENT NEEDS WE HAVE A
SENSE OF HOW THAT WILL ROLL OUT
OVER TIME AND WHAT THE DETAILS
WILL BE- SO THE SECOND CATEGORY
OF EXPENSES ARE SOMEWHERE WE
STILL HAVE A LOT TO WORK OUT.
THANKS THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
THAT IN TERMS OF GENERAL
CONCEPT PAPERS- AND THINKING-
ALREADY JOHN AND SHARED WITH
THE LEGISLATURE I THINK AN
EXAMPLE DAY SO WE THOUGHT
BROADER LEVEL IS TO HELP YOUR
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL AS CALENDARS
DOCTOR AND GO ON AND SHE DID A
DANCE IN IT. CAL AND SO THIS
IS- ALL HHS AGENCIES WEBSITE-
THEIR DOCUMENTS IN TERMS OF HOW
THEY IN THE ADMINISTRATION OR
SOMETHING ABOUT IT WHAT THE
APPROACH IS WHY WE THINK IT'S
FRIENDS THAT WE- HAVE TO FILL
IN A LOT OF THE DETAILS I THINK
YOU CAN LOOK AT THOSE DOCUMENTS.
WHICH ARE EX. AND DISCUSS THE
AGES AND SEE WHERE IT'S- THE
FINAL CATEGORY WHICH I WAS THE
TOUGHEST AYE AREN'T
SPECIFICALLY IN THE
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICING AND
THE TO HELP FOR ONLY. SOME
DETAILS ON FEB FIRST BUT FOR A
LOT OF THESE MISSILES. A REAL
BEEF NEW CONCEPT NO ONE ZERO
SEE SOME OF THOSE PROPOSALS
WILL NOT FULLY BE FLESHED OUT
UNTIL THE SPRING I VERY
CONSCIOUS OF YOUR POINT IN THE
CHERRY POINT THAT MORE WE PUSH
THIS FOR. THE TIME THE LIKE SHE
HAS SEPARATE LIKE A FOR YOU
THAT PEOPLE ARE WORKING AT ALL
HOURS TO GET THESE READY BUT IT
IS TO OUR AND THIS THAT IT'S
VERY AN THAT WILL BE IN THE
RACE. HOUSING AND SAYS TIME TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE IN FOR
YOU DO GET RIGHT. WOULD BE
HELPFUL YES. THANK YOU I MISS
MATHIS. ALRIGHT SO WE WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT BUDGET PROJECTIONS.
ME ON GETTING INTO EVERYTHING
AND IN REGARDS TO YOU KNOW
SURPLUS IN THOSE THINGS MY
BIGGST QUESTION ON MY MIND I
THINK OF THE MINDS OF A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT IN THE
SOUTHERN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. IS
HAVE YOU GUYS DONE ANY
PROJECTIONS ON THE CROP LOSS
DUE TO THE AMPLE FOR CATIONS OF
SIGMA. CIGNA IS GONNA KICK IN
THIS YEAR. YOU'RE LOOKING AT A
30% CROP LOSS. WHICH SOME OF
THE PROJECTIONS THAT I'VE SEEN
GO UPWARDS TO TWO BILLION
DOLLARS WHICH ARE THEN GOING TO
CARRY OVER INTO FREE GOODS
MOVEMENT. WHICH IS GOING TO
CARRY OVER TO POUR CITIES JOB
LOSSES THEIR- YOU KNOW I IN
THERE'S A LOT OF CONCERNS THIS
IS GONNA BE THE- WHAT TRIGGERS
US INTO THIS RECESSION. THAT
EVERYBODY'S BEEN SAYING IS
COMING. SO I MEAN THAT'S ALL
TRUE ASSEMBLY IF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY BECAUSE THE DUST
BOWL. AS A LOSS OF WATER DUE TO
SHAKE MY DUE TO OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS DUE
TO. THE THESE FIGHTS WITH. THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION ON ON
WATER RELEASES AND EVERYTHING
ELSE. IF THE VALUE DOESN'T GET
WATER AND ARE REAL CROPPERS
DON'T PLANT WHICH IS THE
CHOICES THEY'RE LOOKING AT
MAKING IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS. YOUR ENTIRE BUDGET COULD
BE SHOT. THE EXPRESSION YOU
WITH SOMETHING POSSIBLY OVER
TWO BILLION DOLLAR HIT SO ARE
YOU TAKING ANY FACTORS ON THAT
IS THAT ON YOUR RADAR AND I'D
LOVE TO HEAR FROM FROM BOTH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND LA L.
SO ALTERNATE OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE SERGIO'S BEEN WORKING
ON ON HORSES YES. THE THIRD YOU
EITHER WITH OUR FINANCE- NOT
AWARE SPECIFIC NUMBERS ON CROP
LOT THAT WE CAN CHECK IN WITH-
NEVER CULTURE TO SEE IF THEY
HAVE ANY BIG NUMBERS I DO JUST
WANT TO POINT A COUPLE SIGNAL
RELATED INVESTMENTS WE DO
INCLUDE IN THE BUDGET- ONE IN
THE CLIMATE BOND THERE'S ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. THAT'S SET
ASIDE FOR SIGMA IMPLEMENTATION-
THERE'S ALSO AN ADDITIONAL
FORTY MILLION GOING TO THE BARN
WATER RESOURCES OF THAT FORTY
MILLION THIRTY MILLION FOR
CRACKS TO THE CRITICALLY OVER
GRAFTED BASINS THAT HELP THE
POOR PLANNING. RELATED TO THE-
ECONOMIC MEDICATION ISSUES AND
THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR FOOD NAG
FOR THIS WEEK PROGRAM TO HELP
WITH- WATER ENERGY EFFICIENCY
SO WHERE ON THAT'S FANTASTIC
BUT- CAN YOU TELL ME THE NUMBER
THAT. IS AND HOW MUCH IS GOING
TO. FIX THE OUTDATED CONVEYANCE
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE IN STATIC.
AND TO STOP THE WATER LOSSES
THAT WE HAVE THERE. BECAUSE IF
WE CAN'T MOVE THE WATER NONE OF
THOSE OTHER PROGRAMS ARE REALLY
GOING TO BE AFFECTED. SO I
DON'T THINK I'LL KNOW IT JUST
GOING BACK TO THE CLIMATE BOND.
THERE'S ABOUT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS FOCUSED ON REGIONAL AND
INTERREGIONAL WATER RESILIENCE.
AND ALL THAT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS THERE'S MULTIPLE TYPE
THE PROJECT THAT COULD BE
ELIGIBLE ONE OF THE PROJECT IS
WATER CONVEYANCE. THAT'S ONE OF
THE DIFFERENT GOOD POINT THAT
MAY BE ELIGIBLE WITHIN THE ONE
BILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION AND
THE KIND OF THAT'S NOT GOING TO
HELP. WITH REAL CROPPERS
DECIDING ON WHETHER OR NOT CARE
THEY'RE GOING TO PLANT THIS
SEASON OR NOT. SO WHAT WHAT IS
BEING DISCUSSED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN REGARDS TO
THAT. I MEAN PUT PUT YOURSELF
IN THEIR SHOES YET TO MAKE A
DECISION TODAY. WHAT ARE YOU
GONNA DO. THE DECISION THESE
GUYS ARE GOING TO MAKE TODAY
COULD SKEW YOUR ENTIRE BUDGET.
THREE HAVE ANYTHING ON THAT.
YEAH WE DON'T HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL PROPOSALS OTHER THAN
THE CIGNA RELATED INVESTMENTS
AND WATER RELATED INVESTMENT
THAT WE DO INCLUDE IN THE
BUDGET WHICH INCLUDES THE BOND
THING ALTHOUGH THAT IS THAT'S
WHAT I THINK EVERYBODY'S AFRAID
OF- TO FOLLOW UP WITH THE LA-
IF ANY SURE YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
AND- I'M SURE YOU PROBABLY
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING IN FRONT OF
YOU RIGHT NOW- BUT IF YOU GUYS
CAN START LOOKING AT THAT SO WE
CAN HEAR. PROJECTIONS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE MONTHS BEFORE BUDGET
DEADLINES IF THIS IS GONNA HIT
THIS IS GOING TO TRIGGER US I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE AT
LEAST LOOKING AT SOME OF THESE
NUMBERS- BECAUSE WE CAN TALK
ABOUT WE'RE GONNA HAVE SURPLUS
AND EVERYTHING ELSE BUT IF THIS
ACTUALLY HAPPENS. IN THE VALLEY
ACTUALLY DOES A 30% DROP. IT'S
GONNA SKEWED ENTIRE THING. YES
NONE. YET MR IS COMING OVER
I'LL JUST NOTE A- WITH RESPECT
TO- WE DON'T HAVE A MUCH MORE
TO ADD SOME FIRST ON THE MIDST
OF OUR ANALYSIS BUT- SOME OF
THE KEY QUESTIONS THAT WE'RE
ASKING ON THESE PROPOSALS
MENTION BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ARE. REALLY MORE DETAIL
AT THIS STAGE ABOUT WHAT
SPECIFICALLY BEING PROPOSED. SO
FOR EXAMPLE WITHIN THE- CLIMB
UP ON THERE IS QUITE A BIT OF
FUNDING TARGET TOWARD DIFFERENT
WATER RESILIENCY EFFORT- BUT
UNTIL WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
HOPEFULLY FEBRUARY FIRST WE'RE
NOT- WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
TYPE THE PROJECT WILL BE.
TARGETED AND THEN- MY COLLEAGUE
ALSO MENTIONED THE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
TO ADDRESS THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS
OF SIGMA- IN THE AREAS WITH THE
MOST CRITICALLY OVER CRAFTED
BASINS. IN IN AGAIN WITHOUT
PROPOSAL WE'RE STILL LOOKING
FOR MORE DETAIL AND WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF. FINANCE
AN APARTMENT CUT APARTMENT
WATER RESOURCES TO GET MORE
DETAIL ABOUT. EXACTLY WHAT
TYPES OF PROJECTS AND EFFORTS
WOULD BE FUNDED. WITH THOSE
DOLLARS. VESTING SURE THAT THE
GREATEST PUBLIC BENEFIT- COULD
BE ACHIEVED WITH UNLIMITED
ORGANISED AND MORE MONEY TO
STUDY WHAT WE SHOULD. ALREADY
DONE. THAT'S FACT. OKAY THANK
YOU. THE YOU ONE IS I. THINK IT
IS CHAIRMAN. I'M IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE THE STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL NEGOTIATED THE
STATE'S ARE TO PUT THE STATE'S
SHARE OF THE- NATION MY BANK
SENTIMENT THAT THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS INTO
A LEGAL ASSISTANCE FINE- AND
THAT WAS TO PROVIDE FORECLOSURE
HOTLINES SO THEN GOVERNOR
BROWN- IN THE MAJORITY PARTY
DECIDED TO READ THATFIND AND
USE IT TO PAY OFF HOUSING
BONDS. GOVERNOR BROWN APPEALED
THAT DECISION- TWO DOZEN
EIGHTEEN I REMEMBER BEING IN
THIS ROOM VOTING ON THE BUDGET
BILL THAT WOULD RETROACTIVELY
DECLARE THAT THAT WAS A LEGAL
AND JUSTIFIED MEANS- OF USING
THAT SETTLEMENT MONEY. SO THAT
WAS SB. ONE THIRTEEN. THE
GOVERNOR FINALLY PROPOSED TO
DEPOSIT THIS MONEY WITH A
COUPLE OF CATCHES AND THEN ONE
BEING THAT ONLY THE- REVENUE
GENERATED- WOULD BE USED TO FOR
THAT FOR THE HOMEOWNERS. I AM
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IF YOU
COULD ADD SOME INSIGHT AS TO
WHEN THE- PLAINTIFFS IN THIS
CASE BECAUSE IT DID HAVE TO GO
TO COURT MAN AS YOU RECALL THIS
WE WERE ORDERED TO DEPOSIT THAT
MONEY APPROPRIATELY- HOW LONG
IS IT THAT THE PLAINTIFFS WILL
HAVE TO WAIT IN ORDER TO SEE
ALL OF THAT MONEY NOT JUST HAVE
A TRICKLE UP AT ALL OF THAT
MONEY. GO TO THOSE FOR WHOM IT
WAS INTENDED- COM IT DIDN'T
HAPPEN LAST YEAR I'M CURIOUS AS
TO WHY IT DOESN'T APPEAR IT'S
HAPPENING THIS YEAR AND WE SEEM
TO BE SLOW ROLLING THIS AND I
JUST WONDER IF YOU COULD
PROVIDE SOME INSIGHT ON THAT
USHER HAPPY TO- DISCUSS BRIEFLY
SO I THINK THE FIRST POINT IS
THAT YOU ARE CORRECT- THERE WAS
A JUDGMENT. THAT THE PLAINTIFFS
WINE AND SO AFTER THAT
JUDGMENT- I BELIEVE THE FIGURE
WAS THREE HUNDRED THIRTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS AND THAT WAS-
IS TRANSFERRED- I'LL GET YOU
TRANSFERRED OUT OF OUR SPECIAL
FUND FOR ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES
OR RESERVE DROPPED BY THAT
LEVEL- BECAUSE- IT IS FOR THE
SPECIFIC PURPOSES THAT YOU
MENTIONED. SO DE JUDGMENT
BASICALLY SAID THAT UNDER THAT
SETTLEMENT OF THE MONEY COULD
ONLY BE USED FOR SPECIFIED
PURPOSES- SO THEY'RE BASICALLY-
TWO QUESTIONS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THIS IS ON
GOING WITH THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT THE FIRST IS
WHETHER WE WANT TO SPEND THIS
ON A ONE TIME BASIS YOU TO
SPEND IT ALL IN A YEAR OR TWO
YEARS OR ESTABLISH A FINE TO
WEAR IN ANY GIVEN YEAR THE
LEVEL SPENDING WILL BE MUCH
GLASS. BUT THEN THAT MONEY WILL
ALWAYS BE THERE YOU KNOW
WHETHER THE ECONOMY IS DOING
WELL WHETHER IT'S A RECESSION
LIKE THE ONE THAT LED TO THE
FORECLOSURE CRISIS IN THE FIRST
PLACE TO THE ADMINISTRATION'S
APPROACH IS THE SECOND
APPROACH- BUT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE MAY BE DIFFERING.
OPINIONS IN TERMS OF HOW
SPECIFICALLY TO SPEND- IN TERMS
OF THE AMOUNT OF MONEY IN A
GIVEN YEAR OR HOW TO SET UP
DESTRUCTION FOR SPENDING IT AND
THEN THE SECOND QUESTION IS
WHAT DO YOU SPEND IT ON AND SO
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
JUDGMENT IS THAT IT THE MONEY
DOESN'T. IT'S DOESN'T GO
SPECIFICALLY TO THE PLAINTIFFS
IT GOES FOR THE PURPOSE STAYS
IN THE SETTLEMENT WHICH OF
COURSE THE PLAINTIFFS SUPPORT
THAT'S WHY THEY BROUGHT THE
SUIT AND IN PARTICULAR THEY
WERE TO THE AND- FOR. WORK WITH
THE SETTLEMENT. AND THAT WE FOR
APPEAL. A THE END. WHICH IS
NUMBER RENTER- AND PROTECTIONS-
FOR RENDERING HOMEOWNERS WHO
WORKS.IN FORECLOSURE AT RISK
OF FORECLOSURE OFTEN THEY DON'T
HAVE THE LEGAL ASSISTANCE THEY
NEED. IN THESE VERY COMPLICATED
PROCEEDINGS AND WE SAW THAT
DURING THE FINANCIAL CRISIS. SO
THIS MONEY COULD HELP AND I GET
SECOND IS THE BROADER CATEGORY
OF BORROWER FOR WEEKS AND
THAT'S A SENT OUT PHRASE THAT
YOU WOULD SEE IN THE ORIGINAL.
SETTLEMENT IN TERMS OF THE
JUDGE'S INSTRUCTIONS- AND THEN
THE FINAL POINT YOU RACES THE
TIME LINE SO LAST FALL- WERE
THE INITIAL. DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THIS WITH THE LEGISLATURE WHEN
THE GOVERNOR ROLLED OUT HIS
CONCEPT FOR IT- YOU ARE CORRECT
THAT OUT IT'S ONLY A COUPLE
SENTENCES IN OUR EIGHT PAGES IN
THIS BUDGET- WE DO HAVE
ADDITIONAL WORK TO DO TO
ACTUALLY FLUSH OUT THAT CONCEPT
TO US SO THAT WE CAN SET UP A
TRUST. IF THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVES OF THAT STRUCTURE. AND
THEN GET THE MONEY FLOWING
AFTER THAT- BUT THAT'S
SOMETHING IN THE NEXT COUPLE
WEEKS MONTHS. WE WANT TO WORK
WITH WHAT THE LEGISLATURE. OKAY
THANK YOU MISTRESS THANK YOU
MISTER. OF MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA ASKED A
FEW QUESTIONS ABOUT THE AB SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMITTEE- PROTECTION
PROGRAM I TOO AM VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE REDUCTION FROM THE
FIFTY MILLION TO TWENTY FIVE
MILLION. SHE SO CORRECTLY
STATED IT'S OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
WERE BEING ASSISTED THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM THE INITIAL PART
OF IT WAS THE VALUATION AND
THEN THE FUNDING WAS GOING TO
HELP TO IMPLEMENT THE VERY
PROGRAMS THAT ALL THOSE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS MAPPED TO
DISCUSS THE CAME UP WITH A PLAN
AND NOW THE PLAN WILL BE
SHELVED BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THE MONEY TO IMPLEMENT IT.
THAT'S AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
AREA OF FOR ME WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CHANGING THE
FUNDING INSTEAD OF IT GOING
DOWN WE SHOULD HAVE TALKED
ABOUT IT GOING UP BECAUSE WE
FOUND FROM THE STUDIES AND
FROM. ALL OF THE COMMUNITY.
INPUT THAT THE NEED WAS EVEN
GREATER THAN WHAT HAD BEEN
ANTICIPATED. I AT WHEN WE WERE
TAKING A VOTE SPECIFICALLY ON
THE RIO THROUGH RE
AUTHORIZATION OF CAP AND TRADE.
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT I VOTED
FOR IT IS BECAUSE AB SIX
SEVENTEEN WAS PART OF THAT
DISCUSSION. AND TO SEE THAT WE
ARE GOING IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION IS OF GREAT CONCERN
TO ME. THERE IS A SPECIFIC
QUESTION ON THAT I JUST WANT TO.
LINDA MY VOICE TO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE HAS STATED. ON THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION. THE
FOOD WE KNOW THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S DEVOTION- TOO EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION HAS BEEN
CLEAR AND I DO APPRECIATE- HIS
AND CREATING THE CENTRALIZED
GOVERNING SPACE. FOR EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND FOR ALL
OF THOSE PROGRAMS I THAT'S
REALLY APPRECIATED AND I- I'M
HAPPY TO BE WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR ON THE CREATION OF
THIS PARTICULAR DEPARTMENT WITH
THAT BEING SAID. I AM REALLY
CONCERNED THAT THE BUDGET ONLY
INCLUDES TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THIS- IS THE ADDITION OF
CHILDHOOD SLOTS. WE ALL KNOW
ARE SO IMPORTANT AND WITH ONLY
TEN MILLION DOLLARS
SPECIFICALLY FOR THAT. IT IS A
SERVICE IF SERVICE PROBLEM- WE
KNOW THAT THE OF THE INCREDIBLE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN. WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE AND HAVE YET TO
RECEIVE IT. AND WE'RE NOT
INVESTING ENOUGH WE CAN'T
FIGHT. TO GET RID OF TO RADIC
KATE POVERTY IF WE'RE NOT
TAKING CARE OF THE VERY
pTHE MOST- IF THE CHILDREN ARE.
CURRENTLY IN NEED OF SLOTS. IF
THOSE WHO ARE MOST IN NEED OF
SLOTS NOW ARE NOT GOING TO GET
THEM THEY WERE FALLING FURTHER
AND FURTHER BEHIND AND THIS
FIGHT AGAINST POVERTY IS NOT
GOING TO BE A FIGHT THAT WE
WILL WIN. I DO WANT TO SHARE
THIS CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE IT IS
MY PRIORITY THAT WE INSURE THAT
OUR BUDGET PRIORITIZE IS NOT
ONLY THE WHOLE PERSON CARE
COVERING THE BEHAVIORAL THE
DEVELOPMENTAL AND THE PHYSICAL
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS BUT ALSO
THE WHOLE FAMILY CARE. I THINK
THAT'S PART OF WHAT'S MISSING I
WANT TO BE SURE THAT. THE MOST
HOLISTIC APPROACH TO COMBATING
THE VARIOUS NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S FAMILIES. IS
WHAT'S PRIORITIZED. MY FINAL
COMMENT HAS TO DO WITH THE- TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
TO FOR THAT TO DEVELOP NEW
STATEWIDE REGULATIONS TO REDUCE
OR ELIMINATE EXPOSURE TO TOXINS
FROM INDUSTRIAL AND COMMERCIAL
FACILITIES. IS THIS INCLUDE THE
LOGISTICS INDUSTRY. THAT IS MY
QUESTION. CHOOSE A COLOR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALL HAVE
TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON THAT
LEVEL OF DETAIL I DON'T HAVE
THAT AT MY- FINGERTIPS. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU. THANK AND
CHECK. THANK YOU THIS WORKS.
SORRY THANK THANK YOU I WON I
WON MY COMMENTS AS WELL WITH
WITH- MRS CRISTINA GARCIA AND
MY COLLEAGUE ELOISE GOMEZ REYES
AROUND- EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
YOU KNOW THIS IS A PROGRAM
THAT'S JUST GETTING UNDER WAY I
HAVE TO THESE IN MY COMMUNITY
THEY SPEND A LOT OF TIME
PLANNING WEST OAK WE JUST GOT
APPROVED RICHMAN'S IN THE
PROCESS OF THAT. AND WE'VE MADE
THIS COMMITMENT AND THESE ARE
HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES- AND I
FEEL THIS IN MY COMMUNITY SO I
JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS I SHARE THEM-
TREMENDOUSLY SO JUST HAVE THAT
COMMON AND I'VE TWO QUESTIONS.
YOU KNOW LAST YEAR WE FOUGHT
VERY HARD TO GET MORE MONEY TO
CALVET. THE CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION PREVENTION
PROGRAM- IT HAD BEEN NINE
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR- IT
WENT UP TO THIRTY. BY WAY OF-
COMPARISONS THIRTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN NEW YORK CITY ALONE
FOR ONE CITY IN CALIFORNIA'S
NOW AT THIRTY- WHICH IS NOT THE
FULL BUDGET REQUESTS BUT IT WAS
CERTAINLY AN IMPROVEMENT I SEE
THE BUDGET NOW THIS YEAR'S BACK
DOWN TO NINE MILLION OF
REDUCTION. IN THESE PROGRAMS
THAT WE KNOW WORK AND HELP
REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE AND AGAIN
THIS THESE HAD ARE KIND OF OUR
HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES THAT.
THE NEED THESE RESOURCES SO I
WAS CURIOUS ABOUT. AND THE
THINKING BEHIND THAT- AND THEN
THE OTHER QUESTION I HAD FOR
YOU WAS- AROUND THE GOVERNOR'S
NEW- APPROACH TO HOMELESSNESS-
AND HOW DOES THIS SORT OF. HOW
DOES IT WORK OR DEFER OR
COMPLEMENT. AND THE WORK TO
LOOK LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
DOING KIND OF WHAT'S THE VISION
AROUND THERE FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
TO HOMELESSNESS PLAN. YES SO ON
THE FIRST POINT FOR CALVET- SO
IN THAT PREVIOUS YEARS. IT WE
HAD NINE MILLION DOLLARS BEFORE
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET ACT- BUT
THAT FUNDING WAS ALWAYS ONE
TIME AND SO IT WAS ALWAYS A BIG
LAST- AS I KNOW. MANY OF YOU
KNOW. TO RE AUTHORIZE A FOR THE
COMING YEAR SO WHAT LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET DID WISE- MAKE THAT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING AND
THEN ON TOP OF THAT. PUT A AND
YOU KNOW WHAT WAS EIGHTEEN
ENDED UP BEING TWENTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS OF ADDITIONAL
ONE TIME FUNDING- SO WHAT THIS
BUDGET DOES IS BRING IT BACK TO
THEIR ON GOING LEVEL THAT IS
NOW. YOU KNOW UNLESS THERE'S A
RECESSION OR SOME TYPE OF. MORE
MAJOR SURGERY ON THE BUDGET. IT
WILL CONTINUE TO BE NINE NINE
YEAR AFTER YEAR AND THEN ANY
ONE TIME MINING. MONEY WOULD BE
ON TOP OF THAT- BUT THIS BUDGET
DOESN'T PROPOSE ANY ADDITIONAL
ONE TIME MONEYON THE ON GOING.
OUT WITH REGARD TO THE
HOMELESSNESS- I THINK THE WORD
TO USE WAS COMPLEMENT AND
THAT'S EXACTLY HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION. IS THINKING
ABOUT THIS IN PARTICULAR AT THE
NEW FIND- WHERE WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A LOT OF DETAILS- THAT
NEED TO BE RELEASED IN
RELATIVELY SHORT ORDER AND- MY
COLLEAGUES ARE WORKING ON THAT-
BUT IT'S A SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR FUND WAS THE
LEVEL OF THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED.
AND IT'S NOT REPLACING COUNTY
OR CITY SERVICES ARE ENGAGING
IN THE SORTS OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. IT'S DESIGNED TO
COMPLEMENT THOSE BY NUMBER ONE
TAKING A REGIONAL APPROACH.
NUMBER TWO FOCUSED ON THREE
SPECIFIC AREAS WHICH ARE
STABILIZING BORN HE CARE HOMES-
HOTEL MOTEL CONVERSIONS AND
BROADER AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. AND FINALLY RENTAL
SUBSIDIES AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAVE A REGIONAL APPROACH
WITH ADMINISTRATORS. OVERSEEN
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES- YOUR FOR THE STATE.
AND WITH A LOT OF PERFORMANCE
METRICS AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
SO WE'RE WORKING ON THAT
GOVERNANCE MODEL RIGHT NOW- WE
KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF WORKING
DISCUSSION TO HAVE WITH ALL OF
YOU- BUT- THAT. KEY POINT I DO
WANT TO MAKE IS THAT CITIES AND
COUNTIES WE UNDERSTAND THE
ROLE. THE SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE DOLLARS THAT WAS IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET THAT FLOW TO THEM
AS WELL AS CONVENIENCE OF CARE.
IS JUST GOING OUT THE DOOR
RIGHT NOW I KNOW THE GOVERNOR
AND HIS JANUARY BUDGET. PRESS
CONFERENCE EXPRESSING
FRUSTRATION THAT IT HASN'T GONE
OUT EARLIER. SO WE'LL BE
TRACKING THAT MONEY CLOSELY AND
YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE
THE INTENDED EFFECT AND THEN.
FUTURE BUDGET BUDGET SO I. WELL
THINK ABOUT THESE DIFFERENT
STRUCK. BEST FIT TOGETHER.
THANK YOU MISTER. YEAH A COUPLE
QUESTIONS- FIRST A ON THE
HIGHER EDUCATION SIDE OF THINGS
WE KNOW THAT THE REGION'S JUST
PUT OFF THE VOTE TO DO A
TUITION INCREASE OF THE SYSTEM
IS VERY CONCERNING FOR ALL OF
US WE- WE'VE- MADE SOME
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS LAST
YEAR AGAIN IN THE PROPOSED
BUDGET THIS YEAR. ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE- AND
HIGHER EDUCATION FUNDING- WHAT
IS. YOUR GUYS POSITION AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT HE NEEDS TO BE A
TUITION INCREASE AT UC. SO THAT
AS YOU MENTIONED- GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES A 5% INCREASE
IN BASE LEVEL FUNDING FOR YOU
SEE- AND THE GOVERNOR HAS MADE
CLEAR THAT HE BELIEVES
SITUATION INCREASES NOT
WARRANTED AT THIS TIME. AND IS
THAT ALSO YOUR VIEW AS AT DEAL
HALF SO WE SPEAK FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION. I MEAN BUT I
MEAN JUST IN YOUR GUISES OWN
ANALYSIS OF THE FUNDING. AND
WHAT'S NEEDED AND THEN
RESOURCES THERE DOESN'T NEED TO
BE A TUITION INCREASE RIGHT. WE
SUPPORT THAT GOVERNOR'S BELIEF
THAT THIS BASE LEVEL INCREASE
OF 5% IS. WITH REGARD TO- THE
CAP AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN.
THE ONLY- YOU KNOW HAD HAS
RECENTLY DONE AN ANALYSIS OF
OUR CLIMB IT PROGRAMS. AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT THEY
RECOMMEND TOWARDS THE END IS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
REALLY START THINKING ABOUT HOW
TO HOW TO REALLY INVEST THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS TO
REDUCE CARBON. ONE OF THOSE ONE
OF THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE IS-
FORESTRY MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES
I THINK IN FACT DELEON IS
ESTIMATES ABOUT TWENTY FOUR
DOLLARS PER TON OF CARBON
REDUCED- WE'VE BEEN MAKING
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS THERE
BUT REALLY THAT'S ONLY HAPPENED
YOU IN THE LAST TWO YEARS.
SINCE THAT IS ONE OF THE MORE
COST EFFECTIVE READ AND NOT
JUST BY WAY OF COMPARISON OUR
PS WAS ESTIMATED BY THE LA- TO
BE ABOUT SIXTY TO EIGHTY
DOLLARS. PER TON AND THEY SAID
THAT'S ACTUALLY ON THE LOWER
END OF THE ESTIMATE- IF YOU
TOOK INTO ACCOUNT OTHER COSTS
LIKE INTEGRATION COSTS
TRANSMISSION COSTS ASSOCIATED
THERE WITH- STE THE SOLAR
INITIATIVE HAS BEEN EVEN
GREATER LIKE TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER TON. SO ISN'T THERE
AN ARGUMENT THERE FOR REALLY
EVEN DO EVEN MORE. AND I
APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR FOR MAKING
THE INVESTMENT. YOU KNOW THIS
IS ALSO I SEE PROTECTING US
FROM CATASTROPHIC WILD FIRE BY
REDUCING FUELS. MEN ARE
VEGETATED LANDS BUT JUST FROM A
CLIMATE PERSPECTIVE AND BASED
ON THE LA OWES. RECOMMENDATION
I BE HAPPY HERE FROM THEM AS
WELL. SHOULD WE BE DOING EVEN
MORE. IN THIS FEAR WORDS A MORE
COST EFFECTIVE WAY OF REDUCING
CARBON EMISSIONS FROM SO MAKE A
SPECIFIC POINT IN THAT ALSO A
MORE GENERAL POINT ON THE
SPECIFIC POINT OF FORESTRY
MANAGEMENT- AS YOU NOTED UNDER
SB NINE OH ONE THERE IS THAT
GENERAL TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS- PER YEAR INVESTMENT
AND THAT IS INCLUDED THIS YEAR
AND THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS AS
WELL. IN ADDITION A NEW IN THIS
BUDGET IS AN EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN THIS WHITE
OUR TECHNOLOGY AND THAT SHOULD
HELP WITH VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT- AND SOME OF THESE
ISSUES AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE AT THE CUTTING EDGE IN
TERMS OF HOW WE'RE USING
TECHNOLOGY TO REALLY IMPROVE
OUR MANAGEMENT. OF THESE AREAS
ON THE BROADER POINT I THINK
I'LL JUST SAY THAT ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT THIS BUDGET- TAKES
THIS BROADER TWELVE AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLAR APPROACH IN WHAT
WE'RE CALLING THE OVERALL TO
FIND A BUDGET WHICH IS NOT
NECESSARILY A PHRASE OR AN
APPROACH YOU'VE SEEN IN RECENT
YEARS- IS EXACTLY YOUR POINT
THAT- WE DON'T WHAT WE DON'T
WANT IS A SCATTER SHOT APPROACH
THIS PROGRAM SEEMS GUIDE.
PROGRAMS YOU PRETTY GOOD TOO
INSTEAD YOU WANT TO LOOK AT ALL
THE INVESTMENTS TOGETHER AND
THAT'S CERTAINLY THE GENERAL
APPROACH THAT WE WANT TO CHECK
WITH THIS BUDGET. I AM BROWN
WITH THE LA AGAIN. MAYBE TWO
POINTS MAKE ONE AS SPECIFICALLY.
THINKING ABOUT COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS IN TERMS OF OUR- CAP
AND TRADE EXPENDITURES OR OR
WAITER DIRECTOR- OUR LIMITED
RESOURCES TOWARD DIFFERENT
CLIENT MITIGATION ACTIVITIES.
WE HAVE DEFINITELY ARGUED IN
THE PAST OVER SEVERAL
PUBLICATIONS AND THROUGHOUT THE
BUDGET PROCESS THE LAST FEW
YEARS THAT SHOULD BE ONE
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION- AND I
THINK ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
WE'VE HAD IS IN SOME CASES-
SUCH AS YOU REFERENCED-
PARTICULAR WITH OUR RECENT
pREPORT ON. ENERGY GENERATION
PROGRAMS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO
OUR OWN ANALYSIS OF- IN
ESTIMATES OF WHAT THE COST
BENEFIT RATIO IS FOR DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS WE DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE
THAT WIDELY FOR ALL- PROGRAM
THE INITIATION HAS DONE AN
ANNUAL REPORT BUT I HINK WE
HAVE ANY. SORT OF VALIDATE ALL
THOSE ESTIMATES THAT MAKE YOUR
JOB A LITTLE BIT MORE DIFFICULT
IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO
PRIORITIZE BUT I THINK MAYBE A
SECOND POINT TO IS THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN WHICH WERE
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING. AS WE DISCUSSED IN
THE CONTACT OF AB SIXTY
SEVENTEEN FOR EXAMPLE. YOUR
OVERALL EXPENDITURE PACKAGE IS
A BIT LOWER- THAN IT WAS IN
THIS PAST YEAR. IN SO YOU'RE
GOING TO FACE SOME DIFFICULT
DECISIONS ABOUT WHERE TO
PRIORITIZE THOSE DOLLARS- THE
INEFFICIENT COMPORT WITH ONE
WAY TO DO THAT. BUT CERTAINLY
TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU- AS A
BODY HAVE A DIFFERENT SET OF
PRIORITIES WHETHER THAT'S BASED
PACIFIC LAND COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS OR THE OTHER TYPES OF
CONSIDERATIONS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT AS WELL. SUCH AS-
THE- CO BENEFITS WHETHER THE-
REDUCTION AND OTHER- CO
POLLUTANTS OR OTHER PUBLIC
SAFETY INTEREST THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE THE OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY
AND- PUBLIC BENEFIT INTEREST
THAT YOU HAVE. WE THINK THOSE
ARE ALL THINGS THAT YOU SHOULD
PROBABLY BALANCE IN CRAFTING AN
OVERALL CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN. JUST LAST
QUESTION WAS ON ON THE- POST
CLIMATE RESILIENCY BOND- I
THINK YOU GUYS HAVE IDENTIFIED
FLOOD CONTROL IS I MEAN.
SOMETHING I BRING UP A LOT
CALIFORNIA'S FIRE AND FLOOD.
ALWAYS HAS BEEN AND WE'VE
ALWAYS BEEN VERY FOCUSED ON
FIRE. YOU KNOW FOR FLOOD A YOU
KNOW THE CYCLES ARE THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE FACING HIGH WATER
EVENTS. THE GAME WHERE WE DEAL
WITH A COMMON THEME HERE
OUTDATED INFRASTRUCTURE OUR
LEVEES ARE IN NEED OF REPAIR
AND IMPROVEMENT. HAVE YOU GUYS
HAD DISCUSSIONS ABOUT TRYING TO
REALLY INCREASE THE INVESTMENT
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE I BELIEVE
THE CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD
PROTECTION PLAN IDENTIFIES
TWENTY SEVEN BILLION. THERE WE
NEED TO PUT INTO OUR OUR I LOVE
THE SYSTEM- ARE WE MAKING
INROADS ON THAT AND WHAT IN THE
BUDGET ARE WE DOING TO REALLY
ADDRESS. THE OTHER. POTENTIAL
FOR CATASTROPHIC EVENTS IN
FLOODS YES SO- I'LL- THE BOND
THAT YOU MENTIONED- OVER SIX
OVER HALF OF IT- IS DEVOTED TO
A WATER PRIORITIES AND THAT'S
MORE THAN FLOOD UNITS ALSO
DROUGHT AND- OTHER ISSUES BUT A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF IT IS-
DIVERSIFIED PROTECTION I'LL LET
MY COLLEAGUE SERGIO TALK ABOUT
SOME OF THE SPECIFICS. BOTH THE
DRIVER WITH THE PART OF FINANCE
SO JUST TO KNOW THERE'S A OVER
SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AS
PROPOSED WITHIN HE CLIMATE
BONTA SPECIFIC FOR FLOOD
PROJECTS- THREE HUNDRED FORTY
IS FOCUSED ON. US ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEER PROJECTS IN URBAN
AREAS AND TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
IS FOR SYSTEM WHY MORE TYPE
BENEFIT FLOOD PROJECTS. IN
ADDITION TO THAT THERE'S ALSO
ADDITIONAL FORTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS- GENERAL FUND ONE TIME
TO PROPOSED AS PART OF THE
BUDGET. DELL SO FOR- THE US
ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEER PROJECT
THERE WAS A BIG INFUSION OF
FEDERAL DOLLARS THIS PAST YEAR
SO TO HELP LEVERAGES FEDERAL
DOLLARS. WE ADDED ADDITIONAL I
DON'T WONDER HAS BEEN AN
ADDITION TO THE- FUNDING FOR
BOTH IN THE BOND. THIS
REGARDING THANK YOU THE LAST
ONE MISTER CHAIR MY IT. OKAY NO
NO NO. FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU
TO THE APARTMENT FINANCE IN THE
ALLEY- FOR THE REVIEW I- LOOK I
WON'T GET INTO GREAT DETAIL THE
DAY WILL SPEND FIFTY HOURS
TOGETHER THIS SPRING GOING OVER
THE EDUCATION PIECE IN GREAT
DETAIL AND ALSO WANTED IT TAKE
MISTER TEEING IN OUR OUR BUDGET
SHARE FOR. THE WORK IN THE- IN
THE INTERIM LAYING OUT THAT THE
BUDGET BLUEPRINT ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSEMBLY DEMOCRATS AND-
WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE MANY OF
THE ELEMENTS ARE INCLUDED IN
THIS PROPOSAL SO I THINK IT
GIVES US A GOOD STARTING POINT
AND YOU KNOW BETWEEN THE LA-
PROJECTIONS ON REVENUE AND THIS
PLAN WE'RE WE'RE PRETTY MUCH
THERE AND SO I THINK WHICH HAVE
SOME FINE TUNING THINGS THAT
YOU'VE HEARD EARLIER- CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE STARTING POINT
FROM EARLY EDUCATION THROUGH K.
TWELVE. THROUGH HIGHER AT THIS
WITH A TOUCH ON A FEW OF THOSE
AND THEN REALLY ASK ONE
QUESTION SIX WILL GET IN DETAIL
SO ON THE EARLY I'D MISS THIS
YEAR RIGHT RAMOS LAID OUT THE
COMPLIMENTS THE GOVERNOR FOR
LEADING ON EARLY EDUCATION I
THINK IT'S THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
THE THAT CONSOLIDATION I THINK
THERE ARE A LOT OF UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS WE'LL GET INTO SO WE
WANT TO BE MINDFUL ABOUT THAT
AND NOT YOU KNOW PRE JUDGED YOU
KNOW SUPPORTER NOT NON
COMMITTAL NOT SUPPORT YOU JUST
YET. AS FAR AS THE STATE
PRESCHOOL IN THE PLEDGE. FOR
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW I'M
EXCITED ABOUT THAT AND IN
PLEASE THOSE ARE. DOLLARS FULL
DAY. FOR YEARS LOTS OF THOSE
FILL BOTH THE PRESCHOOL AND
CHILDCARE NEEDS FOR THESE
FAMILIES- BUT AS WE HEARD
EARLIER FROM THAT. CHILD CARE
SIDE THERE'S- A COUPLE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. KIDS AND FAMILIES ON
THE WAITING LIST ALREADY. AND
YOU KNOW OVER A MILLION. THAT
ARE ELIGIBLE BUT NOT ON ANY
WAITING LIST AND- THIS BUDGET
HAS SIX HUNDRED SLOTS NEW SLOTS
SO. THAT SIX HUNDRED FAMILIES
THAT ARE. GOING TO GET LUCKY
BUT THERE ARE A LOT THAT AREN'T
SO. WE NEED TO DO SOME WORK ON
THAT SPACE. K. TWELVE IS STILL
A LOT OF JUST. INCREASING THE
LC AT THAT FUNDING- BUT AS
MISTER OBERNOLTE SAID. THIS
WE'RE FINDING IT AND THE LOWEST
LEVEL POSSIBLE THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT- PIECES SO. WE STILL HAVE
A LOT OF DISTRICTS THAT ARE.
THAT ARE THAT ARE STRUGGLING IS
THAT NO THE DID A REPORT. THE
LAST DAY OR TO TALK ABOUT WHY
IS THAT HAPPENING SO WE NEED TO
BE VERY VERY- KILEY SAID ABOUT
THE FISCAL. CONDITION EVER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS INCLUDING MY
JUST RIGHT HERE SACRAMENTO
THAT'S ON THE BRAKE AND RUNNING
OUT OF CASH. AND THEN LASTLY ON
HIGHER ED I JUST WANNA ASK THIS
IS BECAUSE MISTER GALLAGHER ASK
AND IT'S IN THE NEWS LAST
COUPLE DAYS- FOR UC AND CSU%
FUNDING. ON THE FUNDING IS JUST
PRETTY MUCH YOU KNOW. I KNOW
YOU SAY FIVE PERCENT. GENEROUS
AND IT'S BASED FUNDING TO COVER
THEIR BASICS BUT WHEN WE GOT
HOME TO OUR DISTRICTS I LOOK AT
YOU MY MEMBERS AND SANDRA DINO
AND SANTA MONICA AND ALAMEDA
AND- SANTA ROSA. WE TALKED TO.
PEOPLE INTERESTED IN HIGHER ED
THE NUMBER ONE THING THEY ASK
ABOUT IS ACCESS. YOU KNOW MY
NEPHEW MY GREAT KID MY
DAUGHTER. MY NEIGHBOR HAS A
FOUR POINT WHATEVER. AND IS
APPLYING IN THERE'S NO SPACE.
YOU KNOW YOU KNOW IT CSU WE
TURN AWAY LIKE FORTY THOUSAND
QUALIFIED. APPLICANTS EVERY
YEAR MORE AND MORE HIGH SCHOOL
KIDS ARE GRADUATING TAKING THE
A THREE G. COURSE IS. GETTING
READY TO GO ON TO COLLEGE WE
KNOW OUR ECONOMY NEEDS FOR
COLLEGE. GRADUATES ITS IT'S-
IT'S CRYSTAL CLEAR. AND THIS IS
A SOLID BUDGET FOR THE SYSTEMS.
BUT THERE'S NOT ONE PENNY. TO
EXPAND ACCESS FOR THE UC AND
CSU SYSTEMS THERE'S SOME CSU
I'M SORRY SOME YOU SEE IN ROMAN
BUT IT'S REALLY A COMMITMENT
FROM. THE LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
SO. THAT I THINK IT'S AN
UNFINISHED BUSINESS SO WE NEED
TO. TO FIGURE OUT. AND YOU KNOW
I KNOW YOU OPPOSE THE STUDENT
FEE HIKES- JUST WONDER WHAT
YOUR THOUGHTS ON. AS A GO DOWN.
THIS BUDGET PROCESS. ON
EXPANDING. THROUGH THE- ROLAND
SO. AT THE UC AND CSU. SO THAT
MY ONE QUESTION THIS MORNING
THIS AFTERNOON FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO THANK
YOU SELDOM MAKE TWO BRIEF
POINTS AND THEN TURN IT OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE CHRIS FARLEY SAID
I THINK THE FIRST DAYS OUR
BUDGET PROPOSES A 5% INCREASE
AND AS- YOU KNOW THAT'S ON TOP
OF THE EVEN BIGGER INCREASED AT
THE SYSTEMS RECEIVED LAST YEAR
SO WE THINK THIS IS SCALABLE
INCREASES IN FUNDING- CAN MAKE
A DIFFERENCE AND GIVE THE
SYSTEM SOME FLEXIBILITY AS WE
WORK WITH THEM TO. INCREASE
ENROLLMENT AND THEN THE SECOND
POINT I MAKE IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PLACED- NOT
EDUCATION BOND OUT ON THE
BALLOT FOR MARCH AND THAT
INCLUDES FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
UPON FINDING IF VOTERS APPROVE
IT- FOR UC AND CSU AND SO A LOT
OF THAT WOULD GO TOWARD
FACILITIES SO TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOME OF THESE ACCESS
PROBLEMS ARE CAUSED BY A LACK
OF AVAILABLE OR MODERNIZE
FACILITIES. THAT MONEY COULD
HELP WITH THAT ISSUE AS WELL
AND THAT OF COURSE WILL BE
SUSTAINED- BY GENERAL FUND
PAYMENTS OVER FUTURE YEARS- AND
MY COLLEAGUE MAY ONE LAP RACE
WELL. SURE CHRIS FERGUSON
PLAYING. I THINK WE WILL WANT
TO ADD THAT. WALL THERE ARE GEN
INCREASES PROVIDE APPROVAL THE
UC AND CSU WE DID ESTABLISH IN
OUR BUDGET SUMMARY
EXPECTATIONS. THAT BOTH THE
REGIONS AND THE TRUSTEES-
CONSIDER THAT FUNDING IN TERMS
OF ACCESS IN TERMS OF-
AFFORDABILITY IN TERMS OF.
CLOSING ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW RIDE COVERING
THEIR OPERATING COSTS SO WE
DID. ESTABLISH EXPECTATIONS
BOULDER NO SPECIFICS WE WOULD
AGREE WITH YOU- WE DID
ESTABLISH THAT EXPECTATION AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO- A HEALTHY
DISCUSSION ON THE TOPIC. SO
DOES THAT MEAN THAT YOU CAN BE
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT. YUR
MARCO WE'RE WITH. SPECIFICALLY
IN THERE SPECIFYING IN IN ROME
AT TARGET FREE TO THE SYSTEM. I
THINK IT IS AT THIS POINT IT'S
PROBABLY EARLY PRESS TO MAKE
SUCH A COMMITMENT BUT WE'RE
CERTAINLY- OPEN TO THE
CONVERSATION OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS RIVAS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD THINK- THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR THE
PRESENTATION AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND OF COURSE THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE FOR PREPARING- THIS
BUDGET- I WANT TO COMMENT ON
TWO AREAS IN THE BUDGET- FIRST
HOMELESSNESS- I WANT TO COMMEND
THE GOVERNOR FOR PRIORITIZING
HOMELESSNESS- VERY EXCITED TO
SEE THE INVESTMENTS- IN THE
DIFFERENT- HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS THAT YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER IN THE NEW FUND. A YOU
KNOW I THINK WE'RE ALL FEELING
THIS CRISIS- STATEWIDE URBAN
AREAS RURAL AREAS YOU KNOW IT'S
A IT'S A STATEWIDE- CRISIS AND-
YOU KNOW I THINK I FEEL A SENSE
OF URGENCY THAT OUR STATE BE
EFFECTIVE IN RESOLVING THIS
CRISIS AND I THINK- THE
INVESTMENTS IN THIS BUDGET SHOW
THAT I THINK THE GOVERNOR ALSO
FEELS THAT. AND BUT I THINK WE
NEED TO RECONSIDER HOW WE
STRUCTURE OUR ENTITIES THAT ARE
OVERSEEN THESE PROGRAMS YOU
KNOW RIGHT NOW THERE'S MULTIPLE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS
OVERSEEN THIRTY DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS- THAT HAVE TO DO WITH
HOMELESSNESS- AND SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO STREAMLINE
THESE PROGRAMS- IN AND MAKING
US MORE EFFECTIVE AS A STATE IN
DEALING WITH THIS CRISIS. THE
NEXT AREA I WANTED TO COMMENT
ON WAS THE CLIMATE RESILIENCE
AND SPECIFICALLY I WAS
PERSONALLY EXCITED TO SEE THE-
INCREASE IN THE URBAN GREENING
OF PROGRAM YOU KNOW IN THE
BOND- LAST YEAR I THINK IT WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER YOU KNOW
THIS YEAR THINK IT'S ALLOCATE
AT TWO HUNDRED MILLION- LAST
YEAR WAS LOWER AND FOR ME
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT AREAS
LIKE MY DISTRICT IN LOS ANGELES
BUT ALSO- FOR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND- OTHER UNDERSERVED.
AREAS WHERE THE DEAL WITH
EXTREME HEAT IN HOW. THESE ARE
IN IN MITIGATING THAT IN THESE
AREAS YOU KNOW LAST YEAR I HAD
A BILL THAT- PROPOSED YOU KNOW
GREEN SCHOOL YARD SPACE- YOU
KNOW WITH IN AREAS LIKE MINE
THERE'S NOT THAT MUCH SPACE
ALREADY OPEN YOU DON'T URBAN
DENSITY. AND SCHOOL YARDS ARE
PERFECT FOR THAT AND
UNFORTUNATELY WAS VETOED
BECAUSE IT WASN'T IN THE
BUDGET. SO I LOOK FORWARD- AS
PART OF MY THE BUDGETS OF THREE
COMMITTEE AND WORKING WITH THE
BUDGETS OF THREE CHAIR MISTER
BLOOM ON HOW WE CAN INCLUDE-
INVESTMENTS. IN IN IN THIS AREA
SO THANK YOU. MR BLOOM. THANK
YOU. I WANT TO JOIN- OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY AND FROM- BERKELEY AND-
EXPRESSING HOW GRATEFUL I AM
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION'S-
EMPHASIZING HOMELESSNESS IS A
PRIORITY IN THE IN THE BUDGET
THIS YEAR. THE SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
PACKAGE BOB. SEC HAVING SAID
THAT TO THE SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS REALLY IN MY
VIEW FALL SHORT OF WHAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING- AND I THINK
EVERYBODY WOULD AGREE- THAT WE
SHOULD BE TRYING TO DO MUCH
MORE SO I'M- HOPING- THAT TO
WHEN WE GET TO MAY REVISE TIME
IF THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
REVENUES AVAILABLE THAT WE WILL
AGAIN EMPHASIZED THIS AND I'M
HOPING THAT MY COLLEAGUES OF.
WILL EXPRESS THAT MESSAGE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD- SO THAT THAT IS A
UNIFIED PRIORITY FOR BOTH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION- WITH RESPECT TO
THE PRIORITIES AND THE NATURE
OF THESE FUNDS. VIRTUALLY ALL
OF THE IMPORTANT CARE ON WHICH
I'M CARRYING SOME LEGISLATION
AND- CORRECTING WHAT IS OF A
BROKEN SYSTEM- BUYING UP HOTELS
AND MOTELS AND RE PURPOSING
THEM FOR HOMELESS WHICH IS IN
SOME CASES A DOUBLE EDGED
SWORD. MANY OF THOSE MOTELS ARE
CURRENTLY INHABITED- AS LOW
INCOME HOUSING SO THERE'S A
DISPLACEMENT ISSUE THAT WE HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THAN THAT BUT- WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO CREATE A LOT
OF. A GREAT PERMITS PARK
HOUSING IN MOTEL LOCATIONS. OF
AND THEN FINALLY- RENT
SUBSIDIES- ARE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE AT LEAST TEN OF THE
CITY OF THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THREE. INDIVIDUALS AT DAY OR
BEING HOUSE BUT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY INDIVIDUALS ARE BECOMING
HOMELESS AND THE- MAJOR REASON
CAUSING THAT HOMELESSNESS IS AN
INABILITY TO AFFORD- THE RENT
AND THAT ONE IS PAYING. A TWO
FORTY THE COST OF HOUSING. MY
POINT THOUGH IS THAT ALL OF
THESE ARE ONGOING ISSUES
THEY'RE NOT- REALLY ONE TIME
CONCERNS AND SO I WANT TO URGE
THE ADMINISTRATION TO FIND AN
ON GOING- SUPPLY OF FUNDS TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO GO AWAY THIS YEAR.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GO AWAY
NEXT YEAR AND IT'S- WELL WE'D
LIKE TO FOR SEE THE TIME WHEN
WE REACH EQUILIBRIUM- OR BETTER
ON ON THIS ISSUE IT'S NOT IN
THE NEXT FEW YEARS- AND IT
CERTAINLY WON'T BE UNLESS WE
PROVIDE THAT ONGOING SOURCE OF-
OF FUNDING. SO I THINK WE
SHOULD ALL BE THINKING ABOUT
HOW WE CAN ACCOMMODATE TO- TO
THAT REALITY. SWITCHING GEARS-
I WANTED TO ASK A QUESTION
RELATING TO THE A BILLION
DOLLAR- PACKAGE ON CLIMATE
RESILIENCY THAT INVOLVES A
REVOLVING. LOAN PROGRAM FOR
SMALL THERE'S ONLY TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS
YEAR BUDGET- AND IT'S A- THREE
FOR THE OTHER STUFF FIFTY
MILLION. COULD BE A ALLOCATE
THE THAT'S REALLY UP PROMISES
NOT A THIS YEAR BUDGET TO- OUT
I JUST THINK WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND TO OF THE ACTUAL
DOLLARS HERE. BUT AGAIN AS WITH
MANY OF THE ISSUES THAT WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT TODAY THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF DETAIL IN THE IN THE
BUDGET AND THE- NUMBER ONE
QUESTION I HAVE IS- WHAT IS THE
ROLE OF THE LEGISLATURE GOING
TO BE. IN DETERMINING WHICH
ACTIVITIES RECEIVE GRANTS AND
WHICH ARE MOST APPROPRIATE FOR
LOANS. SO ALL SPEAK- MAKE TWO
POINTS ON THE CLIMATE CATALYST
FUND- THE FIRST IS THAT TIME
RIGHT NAME BY THE WAY THANK.
THE FIRST IS ON THE TIGHTENING
LIKE YOU MENTIONED IT'S TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE DOLLARS
PROPOSED FOR THE BUDGET YEAR.
AND THEN THE OTHER SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IS I BELIEVE THREE YEARS. AFTER
THAT AND I THINK THE REASON WE
STRUCTURED IT THAT WAY- IT WAS
BECAUSE- THIS IS A BRAND NEW
FIND AND WE PUT A LOT OF
THOUGHT INTO IT BUT IT WILL
TAKE SOME TIME AS AS WE'VE SEEN
WITH THE HOMELESSNESS MONEY. TO
ACTUALLY GET THOSE FINDS OUT
THE DOOR SO WE CAN'T ACTUALLY
SPEND- BILL OR LOAN OUT ACTION
SAY SPEND ALONE OUT OF BILLION
DOLLARS IN THE FIRST OR EVEN
THE FIRST TWO YEARS. OF THE
PROGRAM SO THE WAY THAT IT'S
STRUCTURED RIGHT NOW WITH TWO
FIFTY UP FRONT AND CENTER FIFTY
WAITER. SHOULDN'T REALLY IMPEDE
THE ACTIVITIES OF THE NEW
ENTITY IN ANY SIGNIFICANT WAY-
AND THEN TO THE COMMITMENT
POINT A WEEK TO HOLD IN THE-
MULTI YEAR PROJECTIONS OF THIS
OF COURSE IS THE CHART THAT-
GOES THE NEXT THREE YEARS. WE
DO HOLD SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN EXPENDITURES
FOR THAT OUT YEAR. GRANTED AT
YOUR POINT WE COULD BE IN A
RECESSION AT YOU KNOW ANY SORT
OF THING COULD HAPPEN BUT-
ACCORDING TO OUR CURRENT
SPENDING PLAN. YOUR ACCOUNT FOR
THAT AND DECIDE THIS IS- THAT
SEVEN FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IS.
WHEN YOU FROM. BUDGET NOT. THIS
BUDGET YEAR BUT IT IS. SO WHEN
WE TO ARE A- MULTI YEAR X. A
REVENUE IN THAT OUT YEAR AN-
PROJECT. HOW MUCH WORKING SPEND
IN. YEAR WE ARE SAYING- THE
EXPENDITURE FOR THAT YEAR AND
YOU KNOW WE'RE ALWAYS THINKING
WE NEED TO HAVE AN OPERATING
SURPLUS IN THAT YEAR- THAT
SURPLUS NEEDS TO BE AFTER.
SPENDING SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE DOLLARS IN THAT YEAR SO.
IT IS IN OUR SYSTEM IT IS PART
OF OUR SPENDING PLAN. AND YOUR
POINT IF. IT IS TRUE THAT UNTIL
IT'S ACTUALLY ENACTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN THAT YEAR. HE
DOESN'T ACTUALLY GO OUT BUT
IT'S CERTAINLY PART OF OUR PLAN
AND OUR PROJECTIONS- AND THEN
WHEN IT COMES TO BE AT. THE
ACTUAL OPERATION WERE
ENVISIONING THIS. WITHIN THE-
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK- BUT ALSO
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL.
AND LABOR AGENCY PLAYING A
ROLE. AND YOU WILL YOU KNOW AS
WE PUT OUT OUR TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND ADDITIONAL
DETAILS. WE'LL BE SHARING SOME
OF THE KEY AREAS AND OF COURSE
THE LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN. ON
WHETHER THE PRIORITIES OF THE
GOVERNOR BELIEVES ARE MOST
IMPORTANT FOR THIS FIND. ARE
ONES THAT ALSO THE LEGISLATURE
SHARES BUT THE THREE THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT A PARTICULAR. OUR
LOW CARBON- TRANSPORTATION-
SUSTAINABLE ON CLIMATE START
SMART AGRICULTURE. AND WASTE
DIVERSION AND WE BELIEVE THOSE
ARE AREAS WHERE ONE THERE
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR A GENERAL
CLIMATE. FIGHTING CLIMATE
CHANGE- NUMBER TO THEIR AREAS
WHERE- WE SEE GAPS IN THE
MARKET WHERE I FIND LIKE THIS-
IS IN FACT NECESSARY- AND
NUMBER THREE- THEIR INVESTMENTS
THAT CAN BE MADE ACROSS THE
STATE IN BOTH URBAN AND RURAL
AREAS. OKAY WELL I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING. WITH YOU IN THE
ADMINISTRATION MAKING CERTAIN
THAT THE- LEGISLATURE IS ABLE
TO PROVIDE. APPROPRIATE
OVERSTATE ON AN ONGOING BASIS
ON. ON ON THAT FRONT- FINALLY-
I WANT TO COMMEND THE
ADMINISTRATION. ON IT'S
PROPOSAL TO MAKE A CALIFORNIA.
A NO KILLS STATE I THINK
THERE'S A FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR.
PROPOSED ALLOCATION FOR THAT- I.
THINK THAT THE. THIS IS. A
PROGRAM THAT TO. UP TO YIELD TO
RESULTS THE STATE. IN A STATE
WHERE WE MANY. WERE ARE MANY
FOR. OF DOMESTIC. THE SADLY UP
IN SHELTERS ARE NOT ADOPTED-
AND END UP BEING EUTHANIZED IN-
IN THIS DAY AND AGE THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT- WE- SHOULDN'T
SEE IN OUR COMMUNITIES. AND SO
I SEE GOOD THINGS AHEAD FOR
THIS PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS FOR. I THINK HE WAS
CHAIR OF FIRST I'D LIKE TO
ECHO- WHAT IS A MEMBER BLOOM
SAID THAT IN WHEN DEALING WITH
ALMOST AS WE DO STATE NEED
STABLE SUSTAINABLE FUNDING TO
MAKE A DENT- IN- IN THE CERTAIN
ISSUE THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
PLAGUING OUR STATE- BUT THE
TRANSITION TO- MOTOR VEHICLE
COUNT- I DO HAVE A QUESTION IN
TERMS OF ITS SOLVENCY- I
UNDERSTAND BASED ON THE- MOTOR
VEHICLE COUNTS FUND CONDITION.
A STATEMENT THE FUND IS
PROJECTED TO EXHAUST ITS
REVENUE RESERVES BY THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
I KNOW LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE MADE SOME SHORT
TERM- CHANGES LAST YEAR-
INCLUDING- A FIVE YEAR PHASE
OUT OF THE ACCOUNTING- TRANSFER
OF NINETY TO A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THE GENERAL FROM THE
JOHN FUND- TO HELP KEEP THIS
FUND SOLVENT- THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAVE ANY
PROPOSALS ARE PLANS TO MAKE-THIS ACCOUNT MORE SUSTAINABLE-
AND IF SO WHAT ARE THEY- CELL
SPEAK BRIEFLY. TO SAY AYE
NUMBER ONE THIS IS AN ON GOING
AREA WHERE WE ARE MONITORING
VERY CLOSELY AND AS YOU
MENTIONED- THIS IS AN ISSUE
LAST YEAR WE WANT TO SEE WHAT
KIND OF STEPS WE CAN TAKE TO.
INCREASE THE LEVEL OF SOLVENCY
AND SO WE ARE AWARE THAT WHILE
WE ARE PROJECTING IT BEING
SOLVING FOR THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS. IN THAT FIFTY OUT YEAR
WE ARE PROJECTING A DEFICIT AS
OF NOW- SO WE ARE LOOKING VERY
CLOSELY ON THAT. IF ANYTHING
THAT I THIRTY ONE ELABORATE.
YES THAT'S CORRECT- ARE A
PRIMARY FOCUS AT THIS POINT IS
ADDRESSING THE REAL ID. AND I'M
SORRY SAY THAT AGAIN. OUR FOCUS
THIS POINT IS ADDRESSING THAT
THE MORE MEDIA NEED TO THE REAL
IDEA WILL LOOK AT OPTIONS AFTER
THAT OKAY SO IN TERMS OF LIKE
PROPOSALS ARE ARE ARE SOLUTIONS
TO MAKE SUSTAINABLE THAT STILL
ONGOING. I'M SORRY IT IS SO IN
TERMS OF WAS A WHAT WHAT IS
WHAT ARE THE WHAT IS THE
MEASURE SUPPOSING I GUESS IN
DETAIL TO MAKE IT MORE
SUSTAINABLE OVER. SOUTH SAY SO
YET FOR THAT FIFTY YEAR WE
DON'T HAVE A PROPOSAL ON THE
TABLE RIGHT NOW- BUT WE ARE
CERTAINLY LOOKING AT IT AND I
THINK. THE CALLER WAS SAYING-
YOU KNOW WE- CARE DEEPLY ABOUT
THE SOLVENCY THE FIND AND I
THINK ONCE WE- HOPEFULLY GET
THROUGH THE REAL ID SEARCH I AS
YOU KNOW THAT DEADLINE IS
COMING IN OCTOBER OF THIS YEAR-
THEN WE'LL HAVE A BETTER SENSE.
O WHAT THIS NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS WILL LOOK LIKE IN TERMS
OF OUR PROJECTIONS AND THEN
WE'LL MAKE SURE THAT CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT IT AT THAT TIME.
OKAY IT DOES THE LA- HAVE ANY
SUGGESTIONS OFFER IN THIS AREA
IN TERMS OF HOW TO MAKE THAT
pSUSTAINABLE. TWENTY FOUR YEARS
IS NOT. VERY FAR AWAY. I AM
ESPECIALLY LOOKING AT IT TOO
AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT. WE'VE DONE SOME WORK
OUT. LIKE BRIAN WILL BRIAN
BROWN AGAIN I MEAN MAYBE JUST
ONE POINT TO ADD IS WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION- BUDGET YOUR
PROPOSAL THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
MORE MODEST FINE SHIFTS THAT
THEY PROPOSED TO MOVE A COUPLE
OF AMINISTRATIVE COUPLE
MILLION DOLLARS IN MEDICAID
DOLLARS OUT OF. THE NBA TO ON
SOME OTHER SPECIAL
TRANSPORTATION RELATED SPECIAL
FUNDS THAT HELPED BY A LITTLE
BIT MORE TIME IN SO ARE- IS A
HE NOTED THE- YEAR OF- THE FINE
GOING INTO THE RIGHT IS NOW
PUSHED BACK A COUPLE YEARS FROM
PREVIOUS ESTIMATE- IN THE PAST
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE NBA- WE'VE
REALLY SORT OF IDENTIFIED IF
YOU KIND OF KEY AREAS THAT YOU
ALTERNATELY CAN LOOK AT AND-
WILL WERE REVIEWING THE FINE
CONDITION AGAIN THIS YEAR. AS
PART OF OUR ROUTINE BUDGET
ANALYSIS BUT YOU HAVE- ON THE
REVENUE SIDE THEIR OPTIONS TO
INCREASE THE REGISTRATION OR
OTHER FEES THAT OF COURSE IS
SOMETHING LEGISLATURE DID JUST
A FEW YEARS AGO- YOU HAVE
OPTIONS AROUND IN THE OUT YEARS
YOU REFERENCE THE- THE GENERAL
FUND TRANSFERS THAT WERE
SUSPENDED THAT- COULD BE MADE
ON GOING- TO REDUCE SOME OF
THOSE- DOLLARS AND MAINTAIN
THEM IN THE NBA. FOR A LONGER
PERIOD OF TIME- IN THEN
CERTAINLY- THERE ARE LOOKING AT
THE EXPENDITURES OUT OF THE
FINE AND SO FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF
THE STRATEGIES THAT THE
MINISTRATIONS CURRENTLY
PROPOSING- AND IS. GOOD
PROPOSES FOR THE COMING YEARS
IS TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE ARE
C. H. P. R. D. AND THE FACILITY
RELOCATION THE RENOVATIONS- NEW
PROJECTS- FUNDING THEM AT LEAST
OF ANY BOND OUT OF COURT SPREAD
THOSE COST FOR THIS
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS OVER A
LONGER PERIOD OF TIME BUT HELP
RELIEVE SOME OF THE- TERM. SURE
COULD CONTAIN YOU BUT WITH WITH
DOING THAT THAT YOU KNOW TO
THERE STILL THE WITHIN TWO
YEARS- NEED TO BE BIGGER. AND
MORE ON WIN SOLUTION. I MEAN
THAT'S THE BIG RIGHT ALL THE
ALL THESE PROPOSALS I MEAN. I'M
CERTAINLY NOT IN NOT IN FAVOR
OF ANYTHING BUT I'D CERTAINLY
THE- THAT THE BAND AID
SOLUTIONS THAT WE'VE DONE OVER
THE PAST FEW YEARS AND I KNOW
IT WAS A MEMBER BLOOM IS AS
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS AS WELL.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS WHERE-
YOU KNOW THIS IS A REALLY LARGE
LOOMING PROBLEM THAT WE
PROBABLY NEED O. TO REALLY
START FOR HANDLING RIGHT NOW-
IN PUSHING OFF YOUR BODY YEAR.
IN A WORK WE WON'T WILL HAVE A
LOT OPTIONS I GUESS IF WE GET
TO TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE- AND
THEN OF COURSE AS YOU MENTIONED
IF WE CAN. DO WE GO INTO
RECESSION OR REVENUE- CHANGES
NO I THINK THIS WOULD
EXACERBATE THE INSOLVENCY MY
CORRECT. TO ASSUME THAT. SO AM
I ARE THESE. I WOULD IS THE
ONLY AS- IS SOMETHING THAT THAT
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION IS. ALSO
REVIEWING OR- OR A THAT ALL
THOSE ON THE TABLE. YEAH SO
ALL- I'LL SEE TWO POINTS ENDING
NUMBER ONE WE'RE DEFINITELY
LOOKING AT. ALL THE DIFFERENT-
SUGGESTIONS AND PROPOSALS ON
THE TABLE AND- WE'VE- MADE SOME
OF THOSE CHANGES IN OUR
PROJECTIONS- THAT THE ONLY A
MENTION IN TERMS OF. POWER
FUNDING FACILITIES- OUT OF THIS
FINE DINO BOTH IN TERMS OF. HOW
MANY AND THE TIMING. UP SO WE
ARE VERY FOCUSED ON THOSE
OPTIONS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE. AND THEN SECOND IN TERMS OF
FOR SESSION AND- THAT WOULD
DEFINITELY AFFECTS. BOTH THE
GENERAL FUND AND OTHER FUNDS-
I'LL SAY GENERALLY THAT THE AND
THE A- IS- MAYBE THAT REVENUE
SOURCES A LITTLE BIT MORE.
STABLE IN AS PEOPLE MIGHT NOT
BE BUYING AS YOU KNOW NEW CARS
THAT THEY WOULD BANKS IT'S NOT
LIKE THEY'RE SUDDENLY SELLING
CARS YOU KNOW IT'S NOT LIKE THE
WAY THAT ALCOHOL MAY DROP OR
CERTAINLY. THE VALUE OF IN
INCOME OR CAPITAL GAINS MAY
DROP- BUT CERTAINLY IN A
RECESSION ENVIRONMENT THERE
WOULD BE ADDITIONAL PRESSURE ON
THIS FUN LIKE OTHERS. OF I
THINK THAT AYE AYE BUT SHOULD
COME AS I AND I THINK THAT IT'S
ONE OF THOSE THE WHERE I THINK
WE'RE NOT REALLY PAYING A LOT
OF ATTENTION TO IT AND I THINK
BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD PAY ATTENTION TO SO
THANK YOU MUCH. THANK YOU
MISTER ROBERTS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND FIRST I
WANT TO THANK THE- GOVERNOR OR
THE HEAD OF THE BUDGET-
INVESTMENTS IN THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITY HERE IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA TRIAL. BUT ALSO-
WITHIN THE BUDGET AS WE START
THE DISCUSSION OF- THE BUDGET
IN PREPARATION IN THE DIFFERENT
COMMITTEES THAT YOU'LL BE
PRESENTING- IN FRONT OF ONE OF-
ALLUDE TO MENTAL HEALTH AND
CRISIS RESIDENCY TREATMENTS I
THINK THOSE ARE AREAS WHEN WE
START TO TALK ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS OUT IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE BEING
AFFECTED. WHEN WE START TO TALK
ABOUT THOSE ISSUES THAT WE
START TO TALK ABOUT THE CORE OF
THE ROOTS OF SOME OF THOSE
PROBLEMS ARE THERE AND I THINK
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT CRISIS
STABILIZATION UNITS THAT'S ONE
THING WE NEED CRISIS RESIDENCY
TREATMENT LONGER TERM TO HELP
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING
FULLY EQUIPPED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO- BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THE HOMES THAT
WERE TRYING TO GET HIM TO. BUT
ALSO I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ALSO TALKING ABOUT OUR
WAS YOUTH POPULATION ARE
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOU ARE AGING
OUT OF THE DIFFERENT SYSTEMS
THAT COULD END UP BECOMING
HOMELESS IN THAT SITUATION AND
TALKING BETWEEN EIGHTEEN-
YOU'RE ALMOST A TWENTY SIX YEAR
OLDS IN THAT SPECIFIC AREA THAT
THERE'S WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
LOOKING AT THE ONE TIME FUNDING
WHICH IS PRETTY LARGE IT AND
HUMAN SERVICES HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THOSE ISSUES- AS FAR
AS BEING PROACTIVE TO THEM SO
THAT WE COULD BE ABLE TO TACKLE
THE HOMELESS POPULATION AND IN
GENERAL- CERTAINLY CRISIS
RESIDENCY TREATMENTS IS
SOMETHING THAT I'LL BE BRINGING
UP IN THE DIFFERENT-
SUBCOMMITTEE SUB ONE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THOSE ISSUES AND
HOMELESS YOUTH AND ECHOING ON-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- LUCID REAVIS
IS COMMENTS ON HOMELESSNESS IN
GENERAL THESE ARE AREAS THAT
ARE VERY IMPORTANT NOT ONLY IN
OUR DISTRICT BUT TO THE STATE.
SO I WANT TO BE ABLE TO MAYBE
HAVE A MEETING PRIOR TO SOME OF
THESE- AREAS SO THAT WE COULD
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE AND YEAH.
ON WHAT IT IS WE'RE DOING ON
THE MENTAL HOW. AND THE REASON
HE TREAT THAT ARE THERE. AS
WELL AS OUR OUR HOMELESS- YOUTH.
THANK YOU YES THANK YOU IT WILL
MAKE SURE SOMEONE FROM OUR
OFFICE FOLLOWS UP WITH YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
COOPER. YOUR AVAILABLE MISTER
ROSES QUESTIONS THE
HOMELESSNESS- A BILLION LAST
YEAR FOR HOMELESS. HOUSING IN
IN SERVICES AND THEN SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY PLAY BILLION THIS
YEAR AND IN MY ISSUE YOU
THERE'S NOT MUCH DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE REALLY KEY ISSUES
ABOUT MENTAL ILLNESS GOING WITH
THAT OR SUBSTANCE ABUSE WE KNOW
THAT'S BEEN A BIG ISSUE FOR A
LONG TIME- ELISE BEEN OVER
THREE MILLION SECOND- COUNTY
SPENT. A LOT OF MONEY CITY
ACTUALLY A LOT OF MONEY IN THE
HOMELESS ISSUE AND THE RESULTS
WERE VERY WERE MIXED THEY WERE
GREAT RESULTS AND I THINK WHEN
THE RESONS IT ME WITH A LOT OF
MONEY AT IT. IN HOUSING JUST
DOESN'T GET IT IT'S MORE THAN
HOUSING IT WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY SO IN THE
STREET. AND THERE IS NO TRASK
IN YOU'LL HAVE CLOTHES BUT YOU
CAN BOOK MOTHER FIFTY ONE FIFTY
HOLD BECAUSE NOT A DANGER TO
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS THE DOCTOR
CAME FOR A COUPLE YEARS AGO
THEY WANT TO HAVE A BILL TO
REDUCE FOLKS EARLY FROM THE
HOSPITAL. THAT RAFI ONE FIFTY
HOLDS BECAUSE THE HOSPITALS-
ARE STUCK WITH A POSITION THEY
CAN'T RELEASE PATIENTS UNLESS
THEY HAVE A PLACE TO SEND THEM
TO SO OUR HOSPITALS ARE OR WERE
FLOWN RIGHT NOW SO WHILE WE'RE
DRESSING PART OF THE ISSUE-
WE'VE NEVER REALLY. ADDRESSED
THE HARD PART WITH THE MIDDLE
HEALTH BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IF YOU
GET A COLDER SKIN YOUR KNEE YOU
CAN GO TO A- CLINIC WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH HELP FOR THAT THE
BILL PARK IN DRUGS AND ALCOHOL
ARE TOO HARD TO GET OFF OF
BECAUSE DRUG COURT. SO I TAXI A
LOT ABOUT IT IT LOOKS AS. IF IT
MAKES RESULT THE MINISTRATIONS
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THAT.
IT ALSO BY THE BIG. ELF IN THE-
IS CONSERVATORSHIP. ON BECAUSE
SOMEBODY'S FOLKS ARE. OF LAW.
IS WHOLE. A LISA CONSERVE. GIMP
SOMEPLACE WHERE- WITH IT BEING
TAKEN CARE OF IN. THE BUT
THEY'RE ON- THEIR MEDICINE. IT
MIGHT BE OKAY A. B. NORMAL BE
ABLE FUNCTION AT LEAST- HAVE A
PLACE TO EAT MORE MILLS. SO I
SEE LIKE I SAID A LOT OF MONEY
BEING THROWN. BUT NOTHING
PERMANENT. AND WE HAVE A LITTLE
INFORMATION FOR THE PAST
EFFORTS OF CITIES AND COUNTIES.
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE SO. I'M LOOKING FOR
SOME MORE INFORMATION ON THAT.
YES A YEAH I'LL MAKE- TWO
POINTED IN MY COLLEAGUES MAY
WANT TO ELABORATE AS WELL I
THINK THE FIRST IS- YOU ARE
CORRECT THERE WAS A LOT OF
MONEY LAST YEAR AND THERE'S A
LOT MORE MONEY THIS YEAR BOTH
IN THE TRADITIONAL MEDICARE
PROGRAMS. EVEN IN OUR PROP
NINETY EIGHT SCHOOLS BUDGET
THERE'S MONEY THESE CAN BE
SCHOOLS FOR MENTAL HEALTH- BUT
I THINK THE WHAT- THE GOVERNOR
SHARES YOUR BLOCK WHICH IS
THAT. WHAT WE NEED IS GREATER
INTEGRATION OF ALL THE SERVICE
AS AN ADDITION. OUT OF TO THAT
WHERE AN ADULT ALWAYS. YOU CALL
THAT COUNTY THAT HELL
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL ITS THIS YOU
KNOW THAT. A CHANCE PROPOSAL
BUT REALLY THE AND- NINE THAT.
IS ALL. WE STRIP OUT AWAY. IS
THESE ARE NOT. ISSUES EXACTLY
TO
YOU AND THE JUSTICE SYSTEM. SO
REAL AND BEHIND THAT POST HOW
DO WE INTEGRATE ALL THE SERVER.
INTO THEM TO WHERE PEOPLE NAY
AND THEN HAVE A DISH ACCOUNT OF
THE- NOT. AT THE STATE WHAT BUT
YOU'RE POINT. AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL SO THE BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDESOVER FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR EACH OF THE NEXT
TWO YEARS THAT ACTUALLY GOES TO
THE COUNTIES. AND THAT'S TO
HELP THEM UPDATE THEIR SYSTEMS
SO THAT WITH OUR HELP YOUR
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL PROPOSAL AT
THE STATE. THAT'S A BIG
PRIORITY THERE'S A LOT OF
MENTAL HEALTH MONEY
SPECIFICALLY IN THIS BUDGET.
GOVERNOR'S ALSO PROPOSED OR
SUGGESTED- THAT THERE BE SOME
REFORMS TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT WE KNOW WE HAVE
MORE DETAILS TO. WORK OUT OVER
THERE- BUT WE WANT ALL THESE
THINGS TO WORK TOGETHER AND
SOME OF THE REFORMS THAT HE'S
HOPING FOR TO SEE IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT. ARE
EXACTLY THE KINDS OF THINGS YOU
TALKED ABOUT WITH REGARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE- WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES BUT ALSO
HOMELESSNESS ARE ALSO OTHER
CHALLENGES. WERE TAKING A WHOLE
PERSON APPROACH TO ALL OF THIS-
AND THEN FINALLY ON THE SECOND
POINT THAT YOU RAISE WHICH IS
REGARD THAT CONSERVATORSHIP-
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN THAT THE
GOVERNOR MADE SOME COMMENTS
ABOUT THIS AT HIS PRESS.
CONFERENCE I DON'T HAVE ANY
DETAILS TO SHARE BEYOND THAT-
BUT THIS IS CERTAINLY AN AREA
IDEA ANY YEAH UPDATES TO THE
WINTER WOULD BE TOO SHORT ACT.
OF THAT HE'S LOOKING AT.
ANOTHER WILL PUT THE VOTERS
LIKE THEY'RE TALKING BUT IN THE
ISSUE BUT I THINK LEGISLATION
TO TAKE CONTROL OF THAT- WITH
THE BIG THIS. BIG ISSUE I DID A
COUPLE WORKPLACE ON. THE ON THE
CANON CONSULTING. GREAT THIS
NOT HAVE A SILO- THE ONLY THING
IS THE SIM WE'VE BEEN-
PRIORITIZE ENFORCEMENT FOR
NUMBER OF YEARS. AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THIS- ON PAGE
ONE SEVEN ON THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET SUMMARY. ENFORCEMENT'S
MISSION ONCE. SO THAT'S WHAT
THE FORCE TO LOOK LIKE THAT IS
VERY VAGUE. SO I'LL TURN OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE CLINT- WHO- CAN
CHERYL MORE IN TERMS OF POWER
THINKING ABOUT ENFORCEMENT THIS
YEAR. IT WILL CLOSE COMING UP.
I WAS LIKE A LOT OF THINGS
FINANCES JUL DOWN ON AND THEN
SOMETHING'S JUST VERY. VERY
VERY VERY OPAQUE. THANK YOUNG
APARTMENT AFINANCE SO I THINK-
THE CONSOLIDATION- IS ONE OF
THOSE PROPOSALS WHERE WE HAVE
MORE DEAL DETAILS FORTHCOMING
IN THE SPRING- AND- THE
GOVERNOR AGREES THAT
ENFORCEMENT IS ON COURSE
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF MAKING-
FUNCTIONAL CANNABIS MARKET AND
SO WE'RE GONNA LOOK INTO THAT
AS WE GO INTO THAT
CONSOLIDATION EFFORT- I WOULD
ALSO POINT OUT THAT- THEY
CANNABIS TAX FUND- DOES PROVIDE
MONEY TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE DEPARTMENT. OF
PARKS AND RECREATION AND
THERE'S ADDITIONAL MONEY THAT
GOES TO THE BOARD OF COMMUNITY
STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS- AND THOSE MONIES
CAN ALSO GO TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FOR YOUTH
INTERVENTION AND ENFORCEMENT SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
CATEGORIES THAT ARE GROWING
YEAR AFTER YEAR. BUT THOSE
CATEGORIES RIGHT NOW DEALING
WITH AP AND MOST OF IT BEING
INCIDENTS HAVE COME BECAUSE OF
THE BLACK MARKET- CANNABIS. SO
THE AGENCIES YOU JUST MENTIONED
AND NONE OF THEM DEAL WITH THE
BLACK MARKET. VAPING ISSUE SO
THOSE ARE GREAT BUT THEY'RE ALL
SEPARATE THINGS THAT REALLY
DON'T GO THROUGH THE PROBLEM.
WE ALSO NATIONWIDE EPIDEMIC
GOVERNOR'S COME OUT SPOKE
PUBLICLY ABOUT IT DOT THE VP.
BUT YET THAT'S A BIG PRIORITY
FOR THE BLACK MARKET. WE STILL
GOT A DEAL THAT IN THAT
OTHERWISE THERE IS NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE VAPING. EMPTY WRONG
ABOUT CORRECT ON THAT FACT. YES
THIS WILDLIFE. NOT A NOTHING
WITH THAT SO. SO. I THINK. THAT
THERE IS AS FAR AS PART THE
CONSOLE. EFFORT THINKING WE ARE
TRYING TO. FOR LOOK AT
ENFORCEMENT AND WHAT WE CAN DO
IN THAT SPACE AND I'M
CERTAINLY- BLACK MARKET VAPING
PRODUCTS WILL BE A
CONSIDERATION AND NOT ANALYSIS
SO THE BIG THING A LOT HERE
LUCKILY BODY BUT- WITH THE WITH
THE- DEPARTMENT JUSTICE ARE
BEHIND. A DESTINATION IN GAMING
THE STATE. DOESN'T PAY THAT
WELL SO THEY HAVE A RECRUITMENT
RETENTION PROBLEM. SO TO LOOK
AT THE STATE IS BEING ABLE TO
HANDLE IT. BY THEMSELVES IT
JUST DOESN'T HAPPEN REALLY
DEPEND UPON LOCALS TO DOODLES
ISSUES. A HAD THE BIG BUST IN
LA WITH THAT ONE COMPANY WAS.
ONE FOR THE BLACK MARKET ONE
FOOT IN THE IN THE- PUBLIC
MARKET IN THEY RELIED HEAVILY
UPON LOCALS. TO DO THAT BECAUSE
THE EXPERTISE HAS GONE UP IN
THE STATE. WHEN GOVERNOR BROWN-
DE FUNDED OTHER BUREAU OF
NARCOTIC ENFORCEMENT THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE SO YOU DON'T
HAVE THE EXPERTISE THERE. IN
THE STATE TO DEAL WITH THESE
ISSUES SO DESPERATE WE TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW. HOW THAT WORKS
ENFORCEMENT PART LIKE I SAID.
ALL THIS IS JUST ONE SINCE IT'S
JUST MENTION ONE TIME SO THAT'S
THE- SECOND SINCE THAT'S A
GREAT CONCERN FOR ME ABOUT THAT.
YOU KNOW HOW DO WE GET THERE.
IF THE ADMINISTRATION SAYS
VAPING IS AN ISSUE WE WANT TO.
WE WANT TO DEAL WITH ILLICIT
MARKET BECAUSE- OTHERWISE I'LL
BE HONEST WITH YOU I HAVE ONE
FOOT IN BOTH MARKETS BECAUSE-
ENFORCEMENT SELECTING A PAY MY
FINE. NOTHING GOOD HAPPENS
THERE'S REALLY NO. YOU KNOW
WHAT TO SPEND TWO YEARS NOW
ALSO FOLKS WANT TO COME IN. AND
GET A LICENSE OR- DO THAT.
THERE'S THE AMPLE TIME. POINT
THIS US TO DROP YOU GOT A
BUILDING FULL. THEY'RE HARMING
OUR CHILDREN OUT THERE. SO I
YES HEY I HEAR YOUR POINTS ON-
THE LOCALS PLAYING A ROLE- THE
BOARD AND- STATE COMMUNICATIONS
FUNDING. WHICH WAS TWENTY SEVEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION IN NINETEEN
TWENTY GROWING TO FORTY FOUR
POINT EIGHT MILLION IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. SOME MONEY IS FOR
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE ALLOWED
FOR. LEGAL ACCESS THROUGH
RETAILING CULTIVATION CAN
RECEIVE SOME OF THOSE MONIES
AND SOME OF THAT CAN GO TO
PUBLIC SEE WHAT THE ACTIVITY IS
KEEPING IT ON THAT THE MAJORITY
OF JURISDICTIONS HAVE NOT
ALLOWED. CORRECT CORRECT SO THE
JURY AT MOODY'S GO TO CHURCHES
THAT ALLOW IT SO THE MAJORITY
OF CALIFORNIANS. WHERE THEY
LIVE OR NOT GETTING THOSE
RESOURCES. SO IT'S IS THE STICK
ON THAT AND THAT'S THAT'S THE
BIG ISSUE OF THEIR THEIR WAYS
TO GET IT BUT- STILL IT DOESN'T
DEAL WITH THE ROOT CAUSE THE
PROBLEM. SURE AND ADD THAT'S A
CONSTRAINT THAT WAS PUT IN
PLACE IN PROP SIXTY FOUR- THAT
THE VOTERS APPROVED IN SO THAT
WERE MOVING THE- PROGRAM ALONG
WITH AS THE- INCENTIVE FOR
JURISDICTIONS OBVIOUSLY I
ASSUME THAT WAS THE INTENT
BEHIND- THAT PROVISION. IN
THERE RIGHT IT'S ALSO TALKED
ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL LOCALS
MAINTAINING LOCAL CONTROL TO.
SO I MEAN THERE'S THINGS ON
THAT BUT THAT'S JUST SO WE KNOW
WE CAN WE CAN FOCUS ON THAT.
THAT THAT IS THAT IS A BIG
ISSUE. AND THEN I JUST HAD ONE
MORE. ISSUE TALK ABOUT. THAT.
ON THE ON THE PROBATION ANOTHER
GOVERNOR- WANTS TO GO REDUCE
PROBATION FROM FROM FIVE YEARS
TO THREE YEARS ON FELONIES AND
ALLOW THE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
I THINK FOR SOMETHING'S FOR NON
VIOLENT CRIMES ARE PROPERTY
CLAIMS YEAH I GET THAT THE ONLY
ISSUE IS. UNDER FELONIES YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CHILD NEGLECT SO YOU CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE SOMEBODY THAT HAS
MULTIPLE CONVICTIONS FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. IN FOR CHILD
NEGLECT SO IF SOMEONE GOT UP
PAST PATTERNS OF THOSE
PRACTICES THEY'RE THEY'RE
PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL PRETTY
SEVERE. DO WE WANT THAT PERSON
OFF OF PROBATION OR DO YOU WANT
TO MONITOR THAT BECAUSE IT IS
DIFFERENT I MEAN ALL
MISDEMEANORS AT BIG DEAL FOR
TIME DO YOU LIVE MAYBE
SOMEONE'S GOING ON I GUESS THE
PERSON IS LIKE A BURGLAR. BUT
AT SOME POINT YOU KNOW IT CAN
BE A ONE COOKIE CUTTER SIZE
FITS ALL I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
WAS GOVERNOR'S INTENT FOR
THOUGH IS CHILDREN HE'S VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT- WOMEN AND
CHILDREN AND SPOUSES WITHOUT
SO. COULD HAVE BEEN VERY IT WAS
VERY VAGUE. AND IT IS THE
INTENT TO DRILL DOWN ON THAT
AND TO. EXCLUDE THINGS BECAUSE
AS WE'VE SEEN IN THE PAST OF
SOME OF THESE COLONEL JUSTICE
REFORMS- WE MADE MISTAKES WITH
THIS SO. I GUESS I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE. THE ADMINISTRATION GET
RIGHT THE FIRST TIME SO. WHAT
WAS WHAT THE PLAN ON THAT TO
DRILL DOWN MORE INSULIN THAT'S
THE QUESTION. SURE I'LL MAKE
TWO POINTS INADEQUATE CAN
OPERATE IN THE FIRST DAYS AT A
PROPOSAL- GOVERNOR OF LOOKING
AT- EVIDENCE THAT SHE SUGGESTS
THAT- FOR BETTER OR WORSE YOU
KNOW WE REALLY GET A SENSE OF
THE FIRST TWO YEARS OUT. HOW
SOMEONE ON PROBATION YOU KNOW
WHAT WILL HAPPEN NEXT BUT MORE
IMPORTANT AND THAT THE SECOND
POINT IS THAT. THE PROPOSAL'S
COUPLED WITH SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING. IN OUR
BUDGET SO IT'S NOT SIMPLY.
LOOKING AT THAT AND- SAY THAT
PROBATION TERM DOESN'T HAVE TO
BE THIS LONG. IT'S LET'S MAKE
IT TWO YEARS BUT WHAT'S REALLY
FOCUS ON THOSE TWO YEARS WITH.
SIXTY NINE DOLLARS AND THIS IS
NOT ONLY IN THE BUDGET YEAR BUT
THE YEAR AFTER THAT AND THE
YEAR AFTER THAT. AND HOPING AND
EXPECTING THAT WITH THIS
ADDITIONAL- SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF SERVICES VERY
INTENSIVE. IN FOCUSED IN THOSE
FIRST TWO YEARS WILL ACTUALLY
GET MUCH BETTER OUTCOMES AND
THEN. WHEN I WON THE LOTTERY. I
THE ONLY OTHER POINT I WOULD
MAKE IS THAT- AS WITH A POINTED
OUT THAT AND MUCH OF THE
RECIDIVISM HAPPENS WITHIN THOSE
FIRST TWO YEARS AND THE POINT
HERE IS TO FOCUS SERVICES AN
INTERVENTION. AND ALLOW FOR AND
EARNED DISCHARGE PROCESS. IT
CREATE INCENTIVES FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE THOSE
POSITIVE BEING- MODIFICATIONS.
AND WE'RE ALSO- HOPEFUL THAT
THE PROBATION DEPARTMENT
CONTINUE THEIR EFFORT TO USE
RISK IN NEED ASSESSMENTS. TO
ACTUALLY TO TURN THE LEVEL OF
RISK INDIVIDUAL AS WHICH MAY BE
ONE. IN THE CAN. KIND. SISTER
DO YOU. YOU TO ACTUALLY
DETERMINE THE EIGHT WHICH THEY
SHOW BE SPUR AND HOW THEY
SHOULD BE SUPER TO HOPEFULLY
GET BETTER I'M SORT OF POP
SAFETY OUT CHEN DO YOU KNOW THE
UNIVERSITY BECAUSE LOVE FOLKS
FROM THERE A VERY LOW YOU KNOW
FOR. THEY'RE NOT SUPER
OPERATION UNANSWERED REYES SO
ONCE ABOUT EVERY CONTACT
BRAYSHAW NO ONE EVER CA OF
FOLLOW UP JUST OUT OF THE CHUTE
THAT THAT THAT YOU IS QUITE
LARGE YOUR YOU'RE YOU'RE WITH
CORRECT RIGHT SO I MEAN SO
THAT'S- REALLY. DOESN'T HAVE
ANY IMPACT FLOWS FLOW STATE YOU
KNOW DOESN'T MATTER ANYWAYS
BECAUSE NO ONE'S A BALL. BUT
STILL I HAVEN'T HEARD THAT MY
QUESTION ANSWERED. SO WHAT
ABOUT THE PEOPLE OF ALL THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. AND CHILD
NEGLECT. IN OTHER CRIMES LIKE
THAT. WILL THEY BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS PROGRAM IF THEY HAD
MULTIPLE VIOLATIONS TO. I MEAN
IT IS IF YOU IF YOU BEACH A KID
MULTI AND- ARE YOU BE. IN
OTHER. MORE THAN ONE TIME.
MAYBE WE SHOULD KEEP  TIGHTER
NO RAIN ON YOU JUST TO MAKE
SURE AND NOT ALLOW YOU THAT TO
YOUR WINDOW SO. IF WE THOUGHT
ABOUT THIS OTHERWISE. I'M
FORCED TO CONCLUDE IT'S A
COOKIE CUTTER ONE SIZE FITS ALL
FOR THIS. I THINK I THINK THAT
THAT TO THE POINT IS THAT- AS
FAR AS INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE ON
SUMMARY PROBATION TODAY OUR
PROPOSAL IS TO ACTUALLY
INCREASE THE UNIVERSE OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE SUPERVISED BY TO
PROVIDING MONEY TO PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS TO SUPERVISE
CERTAIN MISDEMEANOR CRIMES I
THINK DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WOULD
LIKELY BE IN THAT CATEGORY BUT
MORE THOSE DETAILS WILL BE
RELEASED. ON FEBRUARY FIRST-
BUT AND TO THAT POINT ABOUT
WHETHER WE IT'LL BE IT WILL BE
PICKING AND CHOOSING CRIMES ON
THE FELONY SIDE AGAIN IT'S GOES
BACK TO THE UNIVERSE OF MOST
RECIDIVISM HAPPENS IN THE FIRST
TWO YEARS- BASED ON SOMEONE'S
INDIVIDUAL RISK NEEDS- AND
THEIR LEVEL OF SUPERVISION WE
THINK THAT THIS PROPOSAL MAKES
SENSE- YEAH BROADWAY IN THAT.
THAT THOSE RISK ASSESSMENTS ARE
IDENTIFYING WHO NEED THAT
SUPERVISION FOR THAT SHIP
PERIOD OF TIME. IT DOESN'T TAKE
PLACE. OKAY BUT I STILL HAVEN'T
HEARD AN ANSWER TO THAT I MEAN
I'D NHI<c.cyan> YOU'RE THE KIND OF</c>
DANCING AROUND IT MAYBE I'M NOT
GETTING IT BUT IS THAT YOU GUYS
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT THAT
SOME OF THESE CRIMES AND THAT
MIGHT DISQUALIFY THEM. FROM
BEING IN THIS PROGRAM. SAID
THAT THE SIMPLE ANSWER ON THE
FELONY SITE IS O CARVE OUTS
FOR CRIMES I WAS ONLY
SPECIFYING THAT WE NOW WILL
SUPERVISE CERTAIN MISDEMEANOR
CRIMES IN THE CATEGORIES YOU
DESCRIBED. THAT UNSUPERVISED
TODAY BUT- GOING BACK TO NOT
TO. TO TYPE MORE TIME. LIST
OFFICE HAVE CASES RIGHT NOW
THAT ARE THIRTY OR FORTY. AND
THEY DON'T GET AROUND TO SEE
EVERYBODY OTHER ACTIVE
CASELOADS. SO THEY AREN'T
SEEING THEIR ENTIRECASE LOAD
RIGHT NOW- MINIMUM SUPERVISION
SO JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE- ON
SUPERVISED PROBATION. IS I MEAN
THIS WAS COMING AROUND ON A
REGULAR BASIS JUST ONCE IN
AWHILE. BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
THE STAFF IF. YOU CAN GIVE THEM
MORE MONEY. BUT THE AT THAT IS
AN INCREASE OUR STAFFING. SO
THAT YOU ONLY HAVE SO MUCH
CAPACITY TO DEAL WITH THESE
INDIVIDUALS SO. THAT THAT
DOESN'T CHANGE SO I MEAN I
WOULD WORK WITH YOU GUYS- I
SPENT A LONG TIME DOING THIS
BUT- I SAID IT IT'S THE IMPACT.
AND I THINK. SOME THINGS ARE
BEING OVERLOOKED WITH THIS AND
I WOULD LOVE TO HELP YOUR
OFFICE OF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
TO WORK TOGETHER TO FIX SOME OF
THIS BUT- I DON'T THINK THE
GOVERNOR SOMEONE'S. I CONSIDER
REPEAT LOW LIFE FOR BOYFRIEND
BEATER- NO CHILD BEATER SLAP
THE KID AROUND THE MULTIPLE
TIMES YOUR PEOPLE OUT THERE
LIKE THAT- THEY SHOULD BE
SUPERVISED SO. BALLS IN YOUR
COURTS OF THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER LACKEY. ALL RIGHT SO
SEEMS LIKE YOU GUYS HAVE DONE A
PRETTY COMMENDABLE JOB OF
PERFORMING WHEN I WOULD. FEEL
COMFORTABLE CHARACTERIZING AS
THE CAPITALS VERSION OF SO YOU
THINK YOU CAN DANCE AND THAT'S
ALL YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN UP HERE.
VERY VERY DIFFICULT EXCEPT IN
THAT COMPETITION THE
CONTESTANTS DISSIPATE NOT THE
JUDGES AND SEEMS LIKE WE'VE
LOST SEVERAL JUDGES BUT NOT
NONE THE LESS. MINE'S GOING TO
BE SIMPLE. AND IT'S VERY A
DIRECT. AND IT'S A LITTLE
DISTURBING- AND THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET YOUR
WE FINALLY STEPPED UP WE
ALLOCATED A FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE GENERAL FUND IS
SUPPORTER STATES EIGHTY FOUR
RAPE CRISIS CENTERS- THIS YEAR
THAT NUMBERS DROPPED FROM FIVE
MILLION. TO FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
WITH THE RECORD RECORD BUDGET
YEAR THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT. AND THE POSITIVE-
ECONOMIC OUTLOOK. AND WE TALKED
ABOUT CREATING TWENTY FIVE NEW
DEPARTMENTS THIS YEAR. I FIND
IT REALLY TROUBLING THAT- DID
MINISTRATIONS CHOSEN TO DEFINE
THE RAPE CRISIS CENTERS AND I
KNOW YOUR YOUR ANSWER MIGHT BE
THAT THERE'S AN INVESTMENT OF
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS. OF FOR ONGOING FUNDING
TO SUPPORT THESE PROGRAMS BUT
THAT'S COMING OUT OF THE- THAT
WAS ALREADY A AN ADDITIONAL
LINE ITEM- THAT WAS ALREADY.
BAKED IN THROUGH THE PENALTY
ASSESSMENT BUDGET RIGHT. IT
COMES FROM THAT FUND YEAH THREE
SAID USPTA STILL THAT'S A
DRAMATIC REDUCTION FROM. FIVE
MILLION TO ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION. NO SO I THINK OUR AT
THE GENERAL APPROACHES SOME OF
THE FUNDING LAST YEAR WAS ONE
TIME SO THIS BUDGET BILLS IN
THE ON GOING FUNDING THAT YOU
MENTIONED THE ONE POINT EIGHT
BUT- AT LEAST IN THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET THAT- BUDGET ACT
LAST YEAR THE ONE TIME FUNDING
WASN'T INCLUDED AGAIN IN THIS
BUDGET THAT IS CORRECT. SO I
GOT. THANK YOU A COUPLE
QUESTIONS FROM ME SO GOING BACK
TO MY COLLEAGUE MS GARCIA'S
COMMENT ON THE CAP AND TRADE
BUDGET WE HAD SOME DISCUSSIONS-
REGARDING- SOME OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS. ONE OF THE LINE
I'M SO I WANTED TO ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT WAS THE CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM. THE IN
THE PAST WE HAD COMMITMENTS
FROM FINANCE OF COMMITTING TO A
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
BASELINE BUDGET MOVING FORWARD.
OBVIOUSLY WAS SURPRISED THAT
SEE THAT CHANGE. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT WE HAVE CODIFIED ARE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION HOLES
INTO LAW AND- IT'S FOR BROADLY-
PROBABLY AGREED ON THAT IF WE
DON'T. REDUCE THE
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS THAT
WE WILL NOT GET THEIR
TRANSPORTATION AS WE ALL KNOW
IS 40% OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IT'S ALSO THE ONLY
AREA. THAT CONTINUES TO
INCREASE WILL ALL THE OTHER
AREAS HAVE DECREASED WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO HAVE SUCCESS. SO IT IS-
LITTLE BIT PUZZLING WHY THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD REDUCE THE
ONE. CRITICAL AREA THAT WE NEED
TO MAKE PROGRESS ON IN TERMS OF
TRANSPORTATION. IN THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND-
AND NOT LAY OUT ANY SORT OF
ALTERNATIVE HOW WE ARE GOING TO
REDUCE TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS
TO REALLY. RECHARGE CODIFY
GOALS. I'LL MAKE JUST TWO
POINTS FIRST DAYS OF YOU KNOW
BY NOW FAMILIAR WITH THAT
SOMEBODY CHALLENGES AND HAVING
LESS FUNDING THAN LAST YEAR FOR
IT THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
AND I KNOW THAT WILL BE AN
ONGOING DISCUSSION WITH.
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATORS AND THE
GOVERNOR- I THINK THE FIRST IS
WHEN WE WERE THINKING ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S OR WHEN THE GOVERNOR
WAS THINKING ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSAL- IT
WAS YOU KNOW MAKING SOME
DIFFICULT DECISIONS BUT DID
ALSO WANT TO FOCUS ON
PARTICULAR. I DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND YET AND MAYBE
GETTING SOME OF THE FACTS AND
OF COURSE AS WE SAW YOU KNOW
NOT YOU KNOW SOME OF THOSE
PROGRAMS TO CARE CUT AS WELL-
BUT THAT WAS THE GENERAL FRAME
OF MIND BUT WE KNOW THAT THIS
PROPOSAL WILL BE POURED OVER BY
THE LEGISLATURE- THE SECOND
POINT I MAKE IS WHEN IT COMES
SPECIFICALLY TO LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION- WE HOPE AND
EXPECT THAT THAT WILL BE AT.
AREA FOCUS FOR THE CLIMATE
CATALYST FUND. THE COLOR.
CLIMATE CALLOUS FUND IS FOCUSED
ON. INFRASTRUCTURE CORRECT. IF
YOU DON'T HAVE CARS TO CHARGE.
WE GONA CHARGE THAT'S CORRECT
AND THAT IS THAT IS GOOD POINT
WE DO NEED BOTH. SO THEREFORE.
THE THIS IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION THAT
WE HAVE ENOUGH CLEAN CARS ON
THE ROAD AND WE ONLY NEED TO
FOCUS ON CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE SO WE CAN REDUCE
THE- COMMITMENT TO CLEAN CARS.
NO DEFINITELY THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT SUPPORTS
FURTHER ADOPTION OF CLEAN CARS
AND WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE A LOT
MORE TO DO THERE. AND HOW WOULD
WE PROPOSED TO DO THAT. SO IT'S
CERTAINLY CHALLENGING WITHIN
THE CONFINES OF THIS BUDGET- SO
YOU KNOW THIS IS OUR PROPOSAL
IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW WE ARE
STILL FINDING THE C. D. R. P.
IN OUR GENERAL BUDGET IT'S NOT
AT THE LEVEL THAT WAS. LAST
YEAR- BUT OF COURSE WHAT THE
FINAL WILL LOOK LIKE WILL BE
WHEN DISCUSSIONS WITH ALL OF
YOU. IS THERE A- GREATER
PRIORITY THAN CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION IN TERMS OF
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GASES. IT
IS CERTAINLY AT THE TOP OF
THEIR AMONG THAT TOP PRIORITIES
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT-
BUT AS YOU CAN SEE WITH THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF OTHER PRIORITIES
INCLUDING COMMITTEE KEEP BY AIR
PROTECTION INCLUDING FORCED
HEALTH WE WERE TALKING ABOUT SB
NINE OH WIND. SO IT IS
CHALLENGING TO EDUCATE AMONG
THESE DIFFERENT PRIORITIES BUT
CERTAINLY THIS REMAINS A TOP
PRIORITY. IT SEEMS THAT MOST
THE TOP PARTY'S ACCOUNT. ONLY
BECAUSE THERE'S LESS FUNDING
OVERALL DOT THEN HOW DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES FOR
TRANSPORTATION GIVEN THE
SHORTFALL IN. GREEN AT THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND.
I THINK WE WANT TO CONTINUE OUR
EFFORTS SAID WITH CAP AND TRADE
FUNDING IT MAY NOT BE AT THE
LEVEL THAT IT WAS LAST YEAR- P.
R. CERTAINLY  THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE ARE HOPING THAT IN MAY
THAT WILL HAVE A BETTER SNSE
OF MAYBE PROJECTIONS WHETHER
FOR THE CAP AND TRADE FIND OR-
GENERAL FUND MORE BROADLY WILL
INCREASE- BUT CERTAINLY THE
GOVERNOR IS TRYING TO DO THE
BEST WITH WHAT WE ARE
PROJECTING THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE. NO UNDERSTOOD BUT
IT'S SORT OF. AGAIN ARE THAT WE
HAVE ON WE UNDERSTAND YOUR
LIMITATIONS BUT AGAIN YOU HAVE
A FUND THAT I DON'T THINK HAS
BEEN TRULY PRIORITIZE ME FOR
EXAMPLE THERE RESOURCES BOARD
WHICH IS UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION THEY- GIVEN THE
SHORTFALL IN FUNDS THAT COULD
HAVE MADE SOME TOUGH DECISIONS
AND REALLY FOCUSED ON ONLY
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION BUT THEY
CONTINUE TO ALLOW PLUG IN
HYBRIDS WITH A- RANGE OF TWENTY
FIVE MILES. SO IF I HAD A PLUG
IN HYBRID FOR MY NINETY MILE
COMMUTE. ARE GET ONLY TWENTY
FIVE OF THAT WOULD BE CLEAN AND
THE REST OF IT WOULD BE. DIRT
BUT I WOULD BE GETTING A
INCENTIVE FROM THAT PROGRAM. SO
YOU KNOW I TOTALLY AGREE THAT.
LESS MONEY MEANS YOU HAVE TO.
BE MORE FOUSED ON YOUR
PRIORITIES BUT IT'S JUST NOT
CLEAR TO ME WHERE THAT FOCUSES
AT THIS POINT BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF MIXED
MESSAGES IT THE MESSAGE SEEMS
TO BE. WORKING TO CONTINUE ON
THE STATUS QUO BUDGET WITH LAST.
IN AND HOPE TO. ACHIEVE OUR
GOALS. VERSUS FOCUSING ON
REALLY WHAT ARE THE- MOST
SIGNIFICANT PRIORITIES. AND
WHERE WHERE DO WE FOCUS LIMITED
RESOURCES RATHER THAN SPREAD
FEWER DOLLARS AROUND ALL THE
AREAS WE HAVE. IT TO ME IT IS
VERY CLEAR IF YOU HAVE A
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
IN TRANSPORTATION IS THE ONLY
AREA THAT CONTINUES TO GROW
WILL GO UP. YOU COULD FIND
AGAIN THIS IS PART OF HIS
PROBATION YOU HAVE INFILL
HOUSING WE KNOW HOUSING FURTHER
AWAY FROM- JOBS IS ABSOLUTELY-
A CRITICAL FACTOR IN TERMS OF
THIS- INCREASING TRANSPORTATION
MISSIONS THAT THAT COULD MAKE
SENSE IF THE IF THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED TO SAY
HEY WE'RE GONNA DO MORE INFO
HOW TO WIN TO LESS. LESS CARS
WOULD USE ONLY GOOD DO ELECTRIC
BUSES AND INFILL HOUSING AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO GO I
THINK THAT TO ME THAT. I MEAN I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH THAT BUT
THAT WOULD BE A PROPOSED. RIGHT
RIGHT NOW WILL BE HAVE IS. WE
LOVE EVERYTHING PACK SO
EVERYTHING'S GET LESS BECAUSE
WE HAVE LESS MONEY. INTO ME
WHAT WE HOPE IS DURING THIS.
DELIBERATIONS PERHAPS WE COULD
HAVE A BROADER DISCUSSION ABOUT
REALLY WHERE WE CAN. I HAVE I
THINK WE OFF THE SAME GOALS
WITH KNOWLEDGE- THAT WE WANT TO
GO REGIONAL SCHOOLS I THINK
COULD BE COULD BE GREAT TO
HAVE. A MORE IN DEPTH
DISCUSSION EITHER IN COMMITTEE
OR IN STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS TO
REALLY FIGURE OUT WHERE WE-
NEED TO PRIORITIZE BECAUSE
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW. I THINK
WHAT'S- WHAT'S BEEN DONE IS-
EVERYONE JUST GOT LESS AND- I
DON'T KNOW MY CONCERN IS THAT.
WE HAVEN'T DECIDED HEY THIS IS
THIS IS REALLY THE- NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY SO THIS IS WHERE WE
SHOULD GO. AND THIS IS WHERE WE
SHOULD GIVE MONEY OR EVEN MORE
MONEY. AND OTHER AREAS WELL
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO WAIT
TILL WE GET MORE MONEY. LATER
SO TO ME I THEY'LL ARE THE
CHOICES DON'T. JUST TAKING CALC
AND DOING SOME DIVISION ACROSS
THE BOARD WAS A TOUGH CHOICE.
IN TERMS OF- EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT. I MENTIONED THAT
EARLIER- COULD COULD OU- I
KNOW THE GOVERNOR WAS A BIG
SUPPORTER OF EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT WE HAVE. A LOT OF VERY
HARD WORKING CALIFORNIANS WHO
JUST. DON'T HAVE DOCUMENTATION
BUT THEY'RE WORKING. THEY ARE
WORKING POOR- COULD YOU
ELIMINATE WHY- PERHAPS THOSE
FOLKS WERE NOT INCLUDED INTO
THIS JANUARY PROPOSAL. YEAH SO
THERE- SO AS YOU KNOW THE I. T.
C. YOU KNOW AN AXE LAST YEAR
THIS BUDGET FINDS IT AT THE
SAME LEVEL AND THOSE FIRST
CHECKS YOU KNOW I GUESS NOW
IT'S JANUARY WILL BE GOING OUT
RELATIVELY SOON AS PEOPLE START
FILING YOUR TAXES. FOR THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TAX YEAR. I
THINK IN THIS BUDGET- IT WAS
SIMPLY A MATTER OF SPACE YOU
KNOW THAT- EXPANDING TO THAT
POPULATION WILL COST. YOU KNOW
OVER A HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
IN TERMS OF THE SIZE OF THE TAX
CREDIT- AND AS YOU KNOW THE
BUDGET MAKES A NUMBER OF OTHER-
INVESTMENTS- HELP UNDOCUMENTED%
INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING ESPECIALLY. ON THE
HEALTHCARE SIDE- SO THIS WAS
SIMPLY A MATTER OF THE
CONSTRAINTS THAT WE FACED. OKAY
THANK. THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THAT IN TERM OF SO THAT THE
HOMELESS IS PROPOSAL
TRADITIONALLY THE LAST TWO
BUDGETS WE'VE- PROPOSE MONEY
ONE TIME MONEY- THE MONEY WAS
MANAGE FINE EACH CD. THIS
PROPOSAL IS REALLY- ASKING THE
S. S. TO MANAGE A DIFFERENT.
PART OF FUNDS COULD YOU EXPLAIN
SORT OF Y. Y. DSS AND GIVEN
THE- AS YOU MENTION THE
COMPLEMENTARY NATURE OF THE
DIFFERENT FUNDED PROGRAMS HOW
WOULD. HOW DO YOU ENSURE THAT
YOU HAVE. TO STATE. DEPARTMENTS
WHO DON'T ALWAYS. TALK TALK TO
EACH OTHER AND COORDINATE THIS
THIS FUNDING WHICH TO ME SEEMS
PROBABLY THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
OF ALL. YEAH SO MAKE TWO POINTS
HAVING FIRST DAYS AT AS YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW FROM YOU HOW WE
DESCRIBE TO FIND IT'S A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT CHALLENGES THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS AND
WE'RE NOT. TRYING TO REPLACE
COUNTIES BUT BETWEEN RENTAL
SUBSIDIES IMPORTANT THEIR HOMES
AND WE DO HOPE TO CONNECT MORE
PEOPLE TO SERVICES- WE DID FEEL
THAT DSS IS THE MOST.
APPROPRIATE VEHICLE- AND
GRANTED THERE'S A LOT IN THIS
SPACE IN TERMS OF HOW WE CAN BE
BETTER ORGANIZED- THE GOVERNOR
EVEN SIGNALED AND IS EIGHT
PAGES ALTHOUGH THIS WILL BE A
LONGER TERM PROPOSITION THAT.
HE'S EXPLORING THE CREATION OF
A UNIFIED WHOLE HOMELESSNESS
AND HOUSING DEPARTMENT OR
AGENCY- SO DEFINITELY THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT AND I THINK THE SECOND
POINT I MAKE- WHICH IS
UNSATISFYING RIGHT NOW BUT-
WHEN THE NEXT. COUPLE WEEKS IS
THAT WE ARE WORKING VERY HARD
ON THE DETAILS OF THIS WE KNOW.
IT'S NEW AND IT'S NOT A FULL
DETAIL AT THE LEGISLATURE CAN
REALLY EVALUATING THE
SIGNIFICANT WAY RIGHT NOW. SO
LITERALLY DAYS IF NOT WEEKS IT
WOULD SET OF WERE REALLY DAYS
FROM NOW WE'RE GONNA PUT OUT
THIS FIRST- COUPLE DETAIL AND
THEN WE WILL DISCUSS. WITH YOU
ALL THIS. PROPOSAL. AS YOU
HEARD. ALWAYS DAHLE WE ALL OF.
WAS YOU KNOW ONE OF THE- MORE
ONE OR TWO TOP PRIORITIES
REALLY THE YEAR DOT ALONG WITH.
REALLY WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
WHAT FIRES SEEMS TO. VERY MUCH
SORT OF TOP OF MIND AS WELL AS
VERY. IN ALL OF OUR CAN. SO WE
GOING TO VERY. SUPPORT IN THIS.
BUT WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. WE HAVE AGENCIES ARE
WORKING TOGETHER. THAT ARE
WORKING COMPLEMENTARY AND SAYS
YOU HAD MENTIONED. AND I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S THE RIGHT WORD IS
THAT THE COMPLEMENT EACH OTHER.
BUT THE CONCERN IS WHEN YOU
HAVE. TO AGENCIES THAT ARE
COMPLETELY SILO WHO. REALLY
DON'T HAVE ANY KIND OF. WORKING
RELATIONSHIP- TO PASS THEM.
REALLY TO. DEAL WITH. HILL THE
MAJOR ISSUE OF THE I THINK WAS
ASKING QUITE BECAUSE ASKING
QUITE A BIT I THINK THE- IDEA
OF HAVING A HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS AGENCIES A REALLY
INTRIGUING IDEA. ON IN REALLY
ELEVATING THE PRIORITY WE KNOW
THAT WE DIDN'T GET TO THIS
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS LAST YEAR
WAS ONE THAT WAS CREATED- EVEN
THE LAST TWO OR THREE YEARS
AND- SOME OF THE HOUSING CRISIS
IN IT IN IT DOES- IT DOES. SEEM
LIKE IT WOULD MAKE SENSE TO
REALLY ELEVATE THE ISSUE. TO A
HIGHER LEVEL KNOWING THAT EVEN.
IN THIS ADMINISTRATION'S TENURE
WE PROBABLY WON'T BE ABLE TO
SOLVE. THE PROBLEM GIVEN JUST
HOW LONG IT TAKES TO CONSTRUCT
HOUSING. ELEMENT TAKES TO
CONSTRUCT- PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING. HE IF EVERYTHING WENT
PERFECTLY DURING ALL OF OUR
TENURE WE CAN ONLY HOPE TO.
REALLY MAKE A DENT GOING INTO
THE TO THE NEXT ADMINISTRATION
FRANKLY. ON REALLY ELEVATING
THE- ISSUE I THINK WOULD. MAKE
A LOT OF SENSE AND ALSO MOST
POORLY ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
COORDINATION. BETWEEN ALL THE
VARIOUS AGENCIES WHO ARE
REALLY. WORKING ON THIS ISSUE
WE YOU KNOW WE WERE VERY PROUD
TO WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION LAST YEAR. ON
NOT JUST ON HOMELESSNESS
FUNDING BUT ALSO AROUND EVERY
HEALTH ISSUES WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S THAT IS. A PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE BUT- SINCE THAT FIRMLY
FOR AND THE- HERE HUMANS PUBLIC
HEALTH AREA AND ENSURING THAT
THERE IS THAT COORDINATION THIS
IS ALWAYS DIFFICULT. SO AGAIN
WE KNOW THAT- YEAH THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS- TOP PRIORITY
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION IS AS
ALLOWS FOR MANY OF US WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET OUR
DIALOGUE IN TOGETHER TO MAKE
SURE. TO MAKE IT RIGHT. HAVING
SAID THAT LET ME JUST MAKE A
FEW JUST FINAL COMMENTS JUST TO
REITERATE I THINK WHERE WE
STARTED- WE THINK THAT THIS
BUDGET IS A VERY GOOD BUDGET-
OVERALL I BELIEVE THAT IT
REALLY HIGHLIGHTS A LOT OF THE
DIALOGUE THAT WENT ON DURING
THE RECESS I KNOW THAT MOST
PEOPLE THINK DURING RECESS WORK
ON AND OFF AT HOME ON VACATION
I DON'T REALLY SEE MUCH OF THE
WORK THAT HAPPENS EITHER HERE
IN SACRAMENTO OR IN OUR HOME
DISTRICTS- WE THINK THIS BUDGET
REFLECTS MUCH OF THE DISCUSSION
PICKING UP FROM WHERE WE LEFT
OFF LAST JUNE. MANY ITEMS THAT
AGAIN WERE- WEREN'T ABLE TO BE
IN A BUDGET WHICH IS ALWAYS
WHAT HAPPENS WERE OR VERY HAPPY
SEE APPEAR IN THIS JANUARY ALSO
I KNOW A NUMBER OF MY
LEGISLATIVE COLLEAGUES WERE
WERE VERY HAPPY AND VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT AND IT
REALLY- AGAIN WHICH
DEMONSTRATES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS DIALOGUING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE BEFORE
PROPOSING SOMETHING IN JANUARY
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT-
THANKS. I'D LIKE LIKE WHAT. TO
HAVE A NUMBER VERY COMPLEX BUT
WE UNDERSTAND THAT NOT ALL OF
THEM CAN BE READY ON JAN TEN
BUT- THAT THE SOONER OR WEEK
AT- EVEN AN OUTLINE OF
INFORMATION THAT THE BETTER SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE YOU KNOW SOME
DIALOGUE AND DISCUSSION AND WE
COULD REALLY UNDERSTAND WHERE.
MANY OF THESE PLACES ARE GOING-
WE VERY MUCH FROM. THE
COMMITTEES POINT OF VIEW I
THINK VERY MUCH ARE IN LINE
OVERALL WITH THE- OVER ARCHING
GOALS OF THE BUDGET- WE SEE
MANY OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
BEEN. YOU KNOW FIGHTING FOR. IN
THIS BUDGET AND WE WANT TO BE
SURE THAT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO KIND OF FLUSH
OUT SOME OF THE DETAILS ALONG
THOSE LINES SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE. THAT THAT DALOGUE
GOING BACK AND FORTH- WE LOOK
FORWARD AGAIN TO SING ALL THE-
DEPARTMENT FINANCE STAFF AT ALL
OF OUR VERY SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARINGS REALLY APPRECIATE
THEIR HARD WORK AND THEIR
PARTICIPATION- DURING THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS IT'S ALWAYS A VERY
ROBUST DISCUSSION AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL. OF THE EFFORT
THAT THEY PUT INTO IT- BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THAT SOMETIMES- WE
CAN'T HAVE THIS FULL DISCUSSION
IF WE DON'T GET SOME OF THAT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE BECAUSE-
A LOT OF TIMES EVEN THOUGH. THE
HIGHLIGHT SOME GOOD A LOT OF
THE DEVIL IS IN THE DETAILS AND
SO WE REALLY. DO APPRECIATE
GETTING THOSE GETTING SOME
LEVEL OF DETAIL AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. SO WITH THAT AGAIN
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE EVERYBODY
FOR COMING AND PARTICIPATING
AND WE WILL BE ADJOURNING THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET.